potatoes collapse to society that's sad
that a root vegetable collapse your
whole society yeah
do they have sweet potatoes too or just
regular potatoes ain't none sweet up
there ha ha ha well you got a [ __ ]
sugar up your tots bro you ain't even I
can't imagine front-end
[Music]
about a world war 2 house came we've got
a bag of gunpowder and chitlins a bag of
chicken correct with do you think Andrew
Santino here today
thanks for coming in man thank you
brother yeah I'm so happy to be this is
I was bragging before we started this is
incredible man no one has anything
that's cool on the wall of all the
podcast studios this was such a smart
idea who's that was this your idea
thanks this was Papio tune I'm not sure
I think we just discussed it Nick what
do we we discussed it and decided this
was it I reluctantly have to give some
perhaps to Gianni let's not give him any
[ __ ] I don't want to give Gianni
props Gianni the twink man he's a sweet
boy oh he got all his meals for free in
New York when we went out to eat really
yeah he was just so cute he walked in
and he winked at the host and she goes
meals on us he said he can make his butt
smile like the crack again he showed me
yeah he bet
well when he when he turned sideways he
can he hoists his shoulders up and you
can kind of see the top of his crack
just lean up just a little bit yeah he's
he's a talented dude I got to tell you a
really cute talent to do it it's too bad
about what happened I know that's it is
what it is look we don't you know his
perversions or his perversions man he
really needs to get some help though I'm
just being honest it's just one of those
things where I feel like a guy like that
he was gonna get caught at some point
for doing what he was doing yeah and
it's down here on the crazy part in this
business when it's downhill brother it
is straight straight down it's directly
straight down I mean we can ask we know
a lot of people that have already
plummeted that far you know Bert's not
putting his shirt off anymore he's
keeping his shirt on
well they had charged somebody filed a
charge against him she did yeah what was
it what you know what just like
indecency or something yeah complete and
decency too much indecency did I run
when I was yelling the first Afellay
even ever masturbated to as a buddy who
had big tits like that you okay how big
were they this boy I don't want to say
his name man because he's a nice boy is
he still alive yeah yeah he's still
alive as far as I know and he I'll just
yeah who was your furs your first crush
do you vividly remember your first crush
oh yeah yeah who was this girl Chrissy
hunt man the name is so hot
and Cheam one of her tooth she was kind
of chipped off a little bit like she had
that lowered Christmas in the front yeah
yeah made her more exotic somehow Oh
Chrissy hunt and I remember she had good
posture that's what I love bro like to
him who was that straight-up [ __ ] over
there
she was just posture yeah just so damn
vertical dude I just felt like she she
stood she stood for some she stood
that's what I felt like yeah for life
she just had confidence in her bones you
know I said that to Steve I was talking
to someone on the way here I said all I
saw at L was in New York when I was in
New York and he's got all these bags he
was hunched over I was like all my
comedic heroes have scoliosis like all
of them are like like they're all like
like kind of like tiny and bent over and
I don't know what that is I can be the
stress the burden yeah the burden of
being so hilarious being at em being so
smart and funny like a tell is probably
the stress tell come a shiz away from
people sometimes too he doesn't like to
kind of be seen I feel like it makes him
nervous right well he's good yeah I mean
I think it's also because I think too
many people want to come up to him and
talk to him yeah cuz he's so funny it's
and and so known but I was watching him
walk and he just like I was just like
and looked paint it looked painful look
like he was kind of like we doesn't do
yoga I don't think he's like a yo you
know he's not that's not one of his
things
no no not anymore um what's going on me
you got the new tour I know I'm doing a
new tour in in 2020 the red Rackham's
awesome man I'm glad franki dude I've
never done small theater this is the
first time I've ever done small theaters
in my life and I'm nervous
we talked on the phone a year ago when
you started doing but you were doing
bigger theaters and then I then I'm
gonna do I'm doing tiny little theaters
but and the nerves are right you were
righteous about you were like excited
nervous and we're we talked on the phone
I was on the 4 or 5 I remember for
coming from the airport and you were
like I'm excited but I'm nervous but
it's it the it's it's dope its I'm so
happy but the pressure is different it's
different than a club I don't know I
don't I don't know why but it is yeah I
just scale the growth you know
yeah the scale the yeah the energy the
excitement for me a lot of it was just
like the how does the words
the room would is like the audio sound
like right because I started worrying
about everything whereas clubs it was I
just gotten used to it I knew kind of
how it went
I knew if it sounded strange how to
adjust it right but in yeah these
different venues where they're all kind
of different it was uh yeah that can be
a little complete here's why cuz they
don't do they don't do comedy shows all
the time right a comedy club only does
comedy shows yeah that's just it's an on
and off switch
but with these venues some of these that
I'm doing the rock clubs rock club yeah
you know Cirque de Soleil or ya off ya
and off like for the circuit yeah gaaaah
they do what i usually on ice do they
Disney on I really did i remember i went
to disney on ice boy i never been we
were fired up were kids man we went
somebody i remember some guy was smoking
a joint at it at disney on ice
[Music]
well really yeah because mostly it was
kids they're not and we're looking at
this guy being like dang dude yeah but
that's but you know he's got to get his
oh yeah i mean it can't hate on that guy
medication yeah well at the time people
it's funny that at the time nobody
sought his medication at the time it
used to be just getting high and now
it's considered medication and that kind
of fascinating yeah well it's only
because people have come around to the
idea that it's not as bad as people want
it to be what do you think will go even
higher what drugs you think we're gonna
get to like a level like some where they
just legalize some cocaine i believe
yeah dominican republic was that it the
dr the dr they got cocaine legal and
they also have frog licking is legal now
to in certain countries you can look for
you can you can lick psychedelic frogs
hmmm what it what i think there's a roof
for sure i think there's a roof what a
denver just legalize mushrooms are they
did colorado that's right yeah a while
now i'll notice you find anything that
i'm gonna see anything on the screen
Mexican Court says cocaine use is legal
for two people Mexico City wow they're
having a la mean with all this what was
the case yeah what happened why would
why do that they needed a to people
should be allowed to use it legally it
says the ruling means the unnamed pair
can use but not sell
according to mexico united against crime
huh they need that energy to get back
and forth and back and forth over that
border you know yeah suck plant ants
like Red Rover
as your Brown Rover I said on I said on
Christa stefanos podcast with Yanis
Papas I said they were joking about
building the wall and I said the wall is
cruel like it's a cruel thing but I
think it'd be funny if it was a maze
yeah like if they had like you don't I
mean if it was absolute American Ninja
Warrior down there I'd be so down for
that well dude and then the people that
would be coming in you'd be getting some
real heroes and super a lot of talent oh
yeah unintel you get some like like
grade-a athletes crossing the border
well I think there should be a return
system that's just what I think it's
like one enters one leaves it's like
there's I wish there was a level in
America for people that don't want to
try and contribute it all to society
yeah that we get to tree you know oh
that's smart like it's like a battle
royale though you have to prove why you
get to stay and someone gonna has to go
yes that's dope that's a great idea
or let Vegas bet on people at a certain
point at the border to like another
point let them bet like just on who is
gonna get can they make it to the next
level yeah it's almost like Mario we're
setting up Super Mario Brothers and
seeing what level they pass it they have
to beat a boss at every point and then
they say they get certain you know you
can get wings you know I mean you get a
jet pack some guys flying Menem laws
going to level 3 yeah I don't know dude
I don't know I think a lot of times
about the border like the people that
live there what is their life like
that's who are really then live at the
border yes like like what is it like for
them you know like well it's easy for us
to judge you know for us to say this or
that but it's like what is it like if
you had like our people running through
people's backyards is it scary or how
people it's gotta be right we used to go
down in college there's a place called
South Padre Island tell yeah we used to
go down there you've probably been down
he probably down to South Texas and
there's a border town called uh damn
Nick you probably have to find it Rosa
no it's called um
Nogales no ha damn bro
but South Padre Island Texas there's a
border town to this big bridge you cross
right it's a massive bridge or Isabel no
it's a Spanish name it's in Mexico that
border town there east of beylin yeah
but let's ISA Belle goes I go there it
is well mark Matamoros that was it
Lamanna horas Matamoros right so we went
in there Matamoros mm-hmm
keep going over to the left and this was
my moto syrtis and this was bad man we
got in the bed of a pickup truck in a
meadow of an f-150 and nine like a 1990
f150 and we and this naamam embarrassed
but I was like in the back and we had
all been drinking and it was bound with
the truck was bounced and bad hmm
and I looked where the bed connects to
the cab and it was like loose mm-hmm
like it was not secure you know I mean
and I looked around I'm realizing I'm
going over this bridge like 80 miles an
hour I was like this is this is how I
died
this is how it ends do you ever go do
like oh if you died in Mexico you wake
back up in America yeah it was like you
start again like urea reanimate but
where do you come back to where's the
city you come back out I think you
probably I'm going probably Columbus sir
toledo toledo toledo sounds Milito or
kansas somewhere in Kansas
that'd be beautiful or just walk
straight out of that cornfield over
there in Iowa right Dyersville yeah yeah
but as you get like a new beginning or
if you could start over you know if you
could but if you could be you
reincarnated you same Theo in another
part of the world so you were born in
another part of the world but you're the
same cat mmm where would you be I'd go
Asia dude yeah I'd be really shocking to
people right you just like damn this
Asian dude is different you know he
sound like that who's this Chinese guy
man you're very unique born and raised
in Pyongyang yeah sound like that you
think you you know how I boo you know I
look like when I went around Japan oh
wow a guy booed me at the train station
I swear to God well do jib redheaded
people and redheaded like type different
type of species and stuff
y'all have behave had not the best PR
how did all this start
I think how do you think it was alcohol
Irish and alcohol and alcohol yeah the
country I've said this what island is a
set as a sad wet island and it's got a
lot of the history is bad man you're
talking about like raping and pillaging
of these poor people
and then who did it well Vikings came
through and raped everybody really
anybody in the North up there right and
then on top of it you have like potatoes
as their potatoes collapsed to society
that's sad that a root vegetable
collapse your whole society yeah
do they have sweet potatoes too or just
regular potatoes ain't none sweet up
there ha ha ha well you got a [ __ ]
sugar up your tots Brian even I can't
imagine running or just right magining
go somewhere finally and they see that
somebody else says sweet but what if
they don't grow up to I don't know
nothing much grows up there but it's
just like but they're fierce man no no
they're tough they're tough people man
they're tough as nails you can kill them
and they won't die no no that like
they're half cats they call them half
cats they got 4.5 lives it's
unbelievable I think but that's how they
build anybody tough when you come when
you come like you're from the south
where people from your area growing up
you know they grew up really tough so
they're naturally just tough people yeah
a little edgier they just have certain
I'm not saying every but certain parts
of places where you had to just grow up
around a little bit more attitude and
edge people tend to be just tougher
mentally I'm not saying they're all
stressed wrong people by physical sense
but they all have to have kind of like
the way to get through strife easier
when you face a lot of stuff like that
you just you see that in tough cities
you know you Baltimore just like oh yeah
that's a tough town to look towards a
tough town to live in dude Baltimore's
the only show I ever had where they had
to stop the show because people were
fighting in the audience is Baltimore
was that for a comedy factory is that
what it was that or no what was I don't
remember the name of that club the Power
and Light District somebody got shot
while I was in Baltimore in that area
the day that I got into Baltimore
somebody got shot and I was I remember
talking to manager and being like man
that's nuts right and he's like that's
not to unka he was like it happens you
know I was like I hope it doesn't happen
this week and he's like no they got they
got one out of the way
they'll be extra security all weekend
what I just come back from that was a I
was just in Indianapolis
it's a strange city yeah wild strange
city yeah I could I've never been I'd
never been to Indiana
other than crossing the border when
we're in high school to buy cigarettes
and booze oh you had to go over there
you are from Chicago where you guys
drove over like by Notre Dame or
something you guys ever go there I went
to Notre Dame one time but when you
cross the border in Indiana you would
get people go for cigarettes and and
stuff because everything is cheaper
everything was cheaper there ah there's
just wait cheaper and then people would
go it's just there was less rules in
Indiana like they just cared a little
bit less yeah oh I could see that they
were more they were more lenient about
selling illegally more places to look
please get certainly a little bit more
lenient out here sometimes I can't
figure out what it is about la that
because there's a lot of things that I
do like about it it's like give the
opportunity you know it's like I can go
do comedy any time I get to be around
like really funny people that like I
look up to and admire you know right and
then and then also like diversity is so
different here it's like here it's like
yeah there's a lot of different
ethnicities everybody kind of gets along
it's pretty chill there's not really
like race I don't I don't ever feel like
racial tension here really yeah but I
think it's also because there's a lot of
this city is pretty segregated and oh
it's definitely segregated no doubt
that's why I don't there's a lot of
tension here because it's almost like
people stick to their neighborhoods here
right like you go in a you go in a Latin
ex you go in a Mexican neighborhood and
it's almost all Mexican and a little bit
of Korean but then Korea towns all
Korean I feel like when you go to other
cities like New York or Chicago it's a
lot more mixed I mean it's it's
segregated still yeah but it's it's it's
like you almost don't have a choice but
to interact because of because of public
transportation hmm we don't do that here
right if there was pop more public
transportation more races would interact
here because people of all colors of
working-class levels that need to use it
mmm you just have to interact or even as
people looking for stuff if people were
like outdoors look you know like
everyone's that everyone's in the car
doing yeah yeah everybody's in the car
you can't even if you see somebody
walking here you're like damn you know
if you hope they're okay yeah you just
some guy walk into the store go and
groceries yeah
who did I see walk I saw a comic walking
today oh it's so weird we he's somebody
walking that you know it's like so
strange
I want to speed up side so they don't
see me I don't want them to see
I don't wanna I don't want to have that
weird hey we it's too little time to
talk so you just have to keep going have
you seen someone in public that you made
eye contact with that you know that you
just don't you don't say how you do you
guys just keep moving mmm there's a lot
of people I feel like that I know by
face but I don't know who they are and I
can't remember how I know them or
anything and so you just avoid it
no no I'll kind of engage a little
sometimes I'll go into a deep
conversation I've always had a tough
time of no one like how well I know
people or not you know like armor and
one time I went to somebody's like
baby's christening or something and
they're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
here dude like you don't even [ __ ]
know no I was like oh [ __ ] man but but
but you but you were being nice you're
like I just want to see the baby give
birth yeah I want to see this the
blessing you know well I was yeah dude I
look bruh and the baptism dude I
freaking still remember of dude I
remember taking a couple extra sips when
on some of that water bra I remember the
first time I stole one of those um the
blood of Christ at a Catholic Church
because you do some altar boy in no I
did none of that really we weren't
Catholic really you you should do is
here's about being a taller altar like a
you know tallest altar boy yeah the tall
boy the taller Boyd that altar boy yeah
that's altar boy huge totally let me
just say this anytime people look at you
they think you've done altar boy do you
think that I did it so I know my kind oh
really you an altar boy yeah yeah I was
saved though I think they knew I would
squeeze that why you got that one
wandering eye yeah I'm just learning
about this because he has to refocus
every couple of seconds you know do you
see it recheck a little bit oh just
checking for the yeah huh he's good but
he's good because he's got he's got his
eyes on a swivel eyes on the Lord
looking for the devil's always looking
for the devil that's why smart cat no we
were we weren't Catholic enough for me
to be a part of the church I also got
asked to leave Sunday school multiple
times I could see that though I just
didn't enjoy the content yeah this was
like I was I was always I questioned
everything that's why I like Jews that's
part of their religion is to question
more Catholics are like don't ask yeah
none of your business
Jews are like Inquirer Inquirer yeah
let's see what's going on let's figure
this out yeah they're all there they're
all depends sometimes the questions
go too far it's like oh dude relax yeah
yes lowdown let's chill out - this is
yogurt yeah you don't get the
fingerprint yeah yeah for Catholics no
we weren't Catholic enough to be an
altar but how many years did you doing
they all all great schools okay through
six Wow I'm not gonna ask you the
embarrassing obvious chief question but
I was it was a traumatic at all did you
hate it I I said I think I was safe
because they they thought I would tell
if sure you like these yeah I wouldn't
let that happen
Mitch the church was so mean my mom cuz
my mom I mean all my family went to
Catholic school and the nuns would beat
their ass oh you know I'm saying like it
would not come in the face Wow they
would smack my mother in the face my mom
said it was a totally normal thing and
no one would say anything if you if you
so much as like made up like one of
those things they would crack you in the
mouth but now people question there's so
much more questioning of the Lord or
questioning of like any sort of like
mainstream parameters it feels like you
know questioning a police questioning of
teachers authorities always had a
society's always had a problem with
authority
yeah and we want we want to know why
they're they treat people certain ways I
mean a power is bias right so Authority
is gonna be biased as well who you are
negative and positive to is inherently
gonna be part of your chemical makeup
and your bias towards who you like and
dislike and all that stuff is
deep-rooted and where you come from who
you were raised around so that's it's
just inherent for us to question
authoritative figures because who gives
anybody the right to tell someone what
to do you know what I mean yeah kind of
like when they say there's no bias in
refereeing or umpiring this is a dumbest
thing I've ever heard in my life
you think there is a hundred percent
because regardless of if if you're if
you're a referee and you're refereeing a
Kentucky game and a Arizona game
whatever the sport is you will have
inherently one closer relationship to
one of those two places because of a
friend a family you know something so
you're gonna just there's gonna be
something in there like a moment in your
yeah like this could have gone either
way I'm gonna give it that way I can't I
just I just don't believe there is a not
there's no non bias in in judging an
authority it just can't exist that's why
that's why I um jury duty is bananas
it's crazy to ask the people
I think that's the crazy it should
become now it's crazier than ever yeah
because now it's like you have people
that are really more like okay I'm over
here I'm over here like if you walked
into a jury now you're gonna look at the
jurors and be like [ __ ] like [ __ ] no
dude understand a chance here or I do
stand a chance or I'm gonna get away
with murder
yeah you either you you you're right
though I think society is doing as doing
this thing now where it's more people
are so much more defined like this for
some reason people are so angry at the
opposition whatever they dislike but
they want to go as far as they can away
from them when you should be getting a
little bit closer to find out yeah why
they feel that way I don't know man up
there's a lack of empathy sometime but
just like it has definitely become and
somebody said they were trying to make
virtual reality so you could empathize
with the way that other people are like
some companies trying to make virtual
reality so you know how it is to be
Mexican you know how it is to be black
you know it is to like you know be no
arms or whatever you know how that you
know nothing or can't read or something
and I'm like well [ __ ] dude nobody gonna
play that game no for some reason a lot
of these white guys aren't playing this
I mean well you know who doesn't get
enough credit Mexican people dude I love
Mexican people met everything in Los
Feliz the per domination of the work
force is Mexican the reason were in
operation is because Amex had people if
if if Mexican people literally left the
Southern California
nothing would function I'm dead so I'm
dead-ass serious yeah they could easily
change the minimum wage if they want if
they all just said yeah if they took a
knee yeah like if they protested I mean
think about every meal almost every meal
I eat is cooked predominately is a lot
of Mexican cooks a lot of Mexicans take
our caretakers of you know everything
from labor jobs to hospice hospital jobs
I mean your fields from grapes to
freakin raisins to human reverence bro
senior citizens human race everything it
never it's just like man and I was
saying but it's like that's it's not
racist to say that why would it be yeah
their partner or their product we're
giving credit to a predominant work
force there
hard-working people who find the jobs
that work for what they can what they
can what they can give versus and I'm
not trying to be you know this dude but
a lot of Americans especially Americans
that were like taking our jobs a lot of
those Americans didn't try for those
jobs anymore so you can't be mad at
people that were hard-working that
wanted something you can't be angry
about that yeah I never get the
hard-working is my favorite attribute of
anybody yeah if you're if you just are
gone if you if you'll stop at nothing to
just continue to work hard and get new
work I don't know how you can be so mad
at that it's your own fault for you you
get in your own way but people want to
get lazy and then they complained yeah
there's not enough work and someone he's
taking my jobs and I don't I promise
they're not taking your specifics and by
the way there's always new jobs being
worked out
someone's figuring out a new job
somewhere I think people just get lazy
and it's easier to complain it's way
easier to complain oh yeah than to do
anything oh I do it like I noticed about
myself on notice I'll do it like with
the industry and stuff you know it's
like just having it cuz I have a chip on
my shoulder a lot of times about the
industry so you don't still yeah I think
it just carries carry it over you know I
think a lot of it I think just from feel
you know over years of feeling like oh I
didn't get a chance you know at so many
people get chances that it seems like
they you would get a chance you know you
would get more of an opportunity even
when I do have opportunities I don't
notice them coz I'm still stuck in that
mindset sometimes you know I feel that
but I mean what would you what would you
want differently now do you know I mean
well what would it be differently at
this point I you know what's funny
sometimes I don't even know and I will
still still get mad about it have that
edge yeah that's funny so yeah I'm just
saying like I can uh that I relate to
what you're saying there because yeah
it's it's just easier sometimes to
complain it sometimes you and here's the
thing a lot so I don't even notice it
about myself you don't know you're doing
it yeah that you have this like kind of
like it's not a self-pity thing but it's
like it's easier to keep that ball in
the air yeah then to let it you know to
get over whatever it is totally and take
advantage of your opportunity totally I
mean I was talking to some of the other
day I won't mention their name but it
just they were talking to me about how
somebody could had kind of hurt them you
can say who it is dude he doesn't he
probably wants to keep it private oh I
thought it was Tulsi Gabbard it is yeah
come all the hair oh she was talking
about she was like that [ __ ]
me bad and I said she's got that bus now
anybody riding on it
she got a bus and then she dropped out
wasn't hilarious that was a funny video
I've ever seen in my life she's like
look at my bus and then like 2 minutes
later she was like she dropped it I
think she just wanted a bus that's all
this is a bus home oh dude I love
policies getting so [ __ ] good bro it
is so many people funny and for all of
these candidates especially like a
Democratic candidates have all just like
they're all just cancelling each other
up before they even have how many
Republicans you know are running by the
way how many can you name no no no today
it's not funny but I can name you ten
Democrats who are like putting their hat
in the ring now I mean Mike Bloomberg is
putting all these lubbers out in he's
well I think he saves the best ratings
but I think Sanderson stands your best
chance over there I guess man I don't
know I think a lot of people have a big
issue with Oh with his platforms and
high dress forms I think just because he
went on Rogan and people got to hear him
and like a real sense that they
definitely about that episode you got to
know him more I'm just saying that he I
don't think he stands a chance to win
but I think he just stands a chance to
get their nomination that's all I mean
yeah that's probably true I think you
know what I think the I was trying to I
was trying to talk about it on stage I
was trying to figure this I think the
like I think the country would love a
regular you know how they say Donald
Trump was a regular dude you know like
he's on America he's really not right I
think I really want a regular ass dude
yeah I think the country would Baron
daran daran from Des Moines Iowa yeah
who just his annual Daniel he's just
doing it yeah I think they ready for I
can't talk about this all day man I
gotta work yeah people like oh I [ __ ]
respect that the president's gonna talk
from 6 to 7 when he gets off of work and
he doesn't do press conferences cuz he's
like I'm busy cooking my kids breakfast
yeah like it'd be nice to have a
president who didn't have all those like
the private chef and the drivers and all
that stuff is just like that they it'd
be nice to have a president of the
people who literally was like has her
normal people scheduled because then he
could [ __ ] about real ass [ __ ] yeah if
he was like nah man my kid the traffic
was crazy today yeah I trying to take my
kid to school and then you know the
window pie had to get the window panes
redone like it'd be funny to hear a
president talk like how average people
have to talk yeah it would it would just
you more connected you know what cuz
everyone's like we need a businessman a
businessman and then when Trump got in
that's what they kept they kept brought
round at businessman but now Democrats
are trying to run on that same platform
ironically enough like Bloomberg
commercials man he that's what he
pushing I'm a businessman but I'm a but
I'm a liberal but it's like you're too
late that game is gone you don't I mean
that's not gonna be the selling no no
person in the middle is gonna go that's
what we needed a liberal businessman
yeah that wasn't why they like Trump as
a businessman it's the opposite they
like the fact that he was cutthroat a
cutthroat business yeah you know what
think things people then want things to
be more cutthroat I think that there's
too much we can do everything yeah
because it's I think some of the proof
is starting to show up in front of our
faces that we can't help every person
it's hard in the whole world
we can't do and I know the goal is to
try to do that yes you want to try to
help everyone you know but the reality
of it is that at a certain point I think
it becomes it's impossible yeah
it no it is it is another really
impossible and so then you're like well
we're America we should do it at least
by example and I agree it's just that in
some ways it's like in the end it comes
down to us it's like we need to help
each other
we're politic worth of where the
president we're the visor it's people
right it's people it's not some you know
thing that's always going on that we can
all point fingers and and blame it's
people and how we treat each other and
how we behave that's either gonna make
or break this overall earth program
yeah for sure well I also think I think
like like go back to like how we started
in villages you know like it takes a
village that old phrase like it takes a
village to raise a child yeah yeah I
think like when we had smaller units and
villages and little bubbles they they
were more functioning because everyone
kind of served a purpose well now we
have so many people and the village is
so large now it's just difficult and now
we're trying to help out not just our
village but a village 2,000 miles away
another state that's really I think
that's what's really hard is other
states trying to solve other states
problems on a federal level
yeah it's super difficult well I love
going back to the state
you know I think it would help a lot I
think it would help people focus more on
like you know what's going on more
locally with them your village you need
it we need more help in our own villages
it's really hard to help other people
I wish we could dude I'm not one of
those people that's like yeah wish we
could to go down it's just but also you
have so many errant people saying like
well what about these people it's a
picture of like nine people starving in
you know Viet Guam and you're like first
of all that's not a place it's not a
real country and that picture could be 2
years old 14 year like it just and
somebody fires it off you know some
angry little gay gentleman he's like
what about these guys you know what
about Terrence and these other guys
nobody care everybody cares yeah and
it's like dude it's so seven thousand
[ __ ] people sitting somewhere with no
job retweeted right and now that's a
thing that's the new thing it's like
that's not the thing dude the thing is
how do I help myself and how do I help
the people that are closest to me I
think well yeah and and and and and if
you have I don't think I don't think you
should be forced to help but I think it
should be encouraged and and it should
be a positive notion right like I'm not
saying yeah everyone with tons of money
should give away all their money but I
think it should be like it should it
should be a cooler notion right yeah
yeah how they try to make I'm not doing
drugs cool you know how they like say no
to drugs like that's cool yeah it's like
they tried that program it's like the
idea should be more but that wasn't that
was cool it was they've tried it but do
remember it would always be can you look
up a say no to drugs dare dare program
car wreck at school school car wreck
they missed every every year they would
bring this car wrecked our school and
they would set it up out of the void see
it right a drunk a drunk driving car
yeah I remember that yeah [ __ ] fat
Lance dude his wife like and that was
the guy's name I'm not calling him fat -
his name was fat nice yeah it was yeah
it was a [ __ ] eight letter letters on
his birth certificate in his first name
it was fat Lance but um they would drive
up with hiked up I like just some
bootleg like lights blaring on the top
of their truck I'm like oh my god
what happened you know and then they
would smell the kids breath upon them
they wouldn't even check the kids pulse
or anything they were alive very
unorganized wanted to make sure he was
drunk yeah oh damn he's drunk
drunken head he's dead and drunk were
you looking for specific vehicles put a
picture up of it now yeah did you or do
it like West Hollywood does that do they
still do that everyone who are they put
our cars in the middle of the city of
drunk driving acts
yeah they just put one out there in
front of the police station every year
oh but it's also like why is it only one
time you think it happens all year round
they just say to the holidays there's
probably the most right there there's
one at school right that's a painted
when they did ours
it was always before prom and the girl
died and then they played Eric Clapton
tears in heaven yes yeah dude I used to
share a room with a gentleman over there
outside of uh in the warehouse district
in New Orleans when I was a loyal low
down there and um
I just learned tears and heaven on the
guitar and he's to make me come in the
room and play a frame and his girl at
night some lady he was banging it really
I used to make my buddy play stairway to
heaven he would do coke and his fingers
would bleed he's strum the guitar so
hard coked out let's test it I loved it
so much I make him play it over and over
the best part about your friends doing
coke playing guitar they'll never not
play the song yeah that's true then
never put that thing down you go man
play that song they'll go you won't put
again so yeah play that again that loop
you till you wake up the next morning I
just learned if I go in there and drop
it three times oh no and then I would
try to play every rose has its thorn me
be like no go back let's go back to the
other one dude yeah that picture was so
ridiculous cuz it looked so they made it
so fake it's just can you bring that
back say it was so fake that's why we
laughed at that and they like and a
member that counselors or whoever that
is like that's not funny
you're like but it that is ridiculous
yeah and they were always and I remember
one year they tried to make it more
ethnic in our town and they were like
yeah la Daryl couldn't handle his liquor
you know where what what county was he
from he wasn't he came over two counties
over Ladera couldn't handle it Terrell
go to that one on the top right to Nick
yeah that one right yeah that's nice
that's what that looks at yeah the one
person was always like shuttled through
the window yeah she wasn't wearing her
seatbelt yeah that was there but you
know what that this is not that's this
isn't funny but how crazy is it that
sometimes when people aren't wearing
their seatbelt it's the only thing that
saves their life mmm that's what blows
my mind when they're like always saves
your life it's like people get flung out
of the car and they say if they stayed
in the car it would have crushed them
hmm but I get thrown out you break every
bone but they're still alive it's just
it's it's like that's why I believe the
funkiness so you can't predict any of
that stuff you're going when you're
going think oh you're going when you're
going I mean you can help you can help
scenarios but I think it's supposed to
happen for sure when it's supposed to
happen
mmm I think if you yes-man but do you
think it's preordained or you think it's
just like that's when the bug when that
roulette ball drop right I think when
that ball drops I think when Jesus wakes
up and has a bad day and he looks at you
and he's like that one's gone yeah that
one's gone this guy's going that guy's
got to go oh this tall altar boy gone
out just altar boys gotta go missed
altar boy with the wandering eye that
kids got his God oh don't get it all the
Christian games he's we can't have that
man we can't have this tall and altar
boy yeah I just think it's there I don't
think I don't like fate I don't like the
word fate but I think I think things
just happen at random but there got
there there's no stoppin do you think
you can do things or behave or operate
in a way in the world that would make
God or a higher power keep you here
longer yeah no no because there's a lot
of people that do a lot of bad things to
other people that kill people that you
that abused people touch them touch them
yeah and they still live so that's how I
don't believe in that system I don't
think it's you can stick around longer
by being a better person I think you can
I think you may physically make yourself
healthier by being a better person which
in turn increases your odds right the
more things you do for people that are
better the better you take care of your
body and your mind yeah you're gonna
spend yourself it you're gonna spend
time in better environment you're gonna
spend time like it's gonna physically
help you have a better chance of living
longer sure but there's probably a
really good guy out there who falls off
rock climbing is a
a good cat but it's just a freak
accident Oh God just did actually let's
bring him up yeah some guy just fell huh
yeah he fell from where a gentleman just
passed last week two days ago or
something one of these rock boys just oh
yeah he was one of the objects of free
solo
he was Bulgarian I think no he was via
Kangin he might be a canyon I think he
was uh jabber agua n-- was he really
yeah that's so you know they can only
see color in one eye
yes in their left I don't know why it is
but it is it's almost beautiful
accomplished free solo Brad go bright
was his name Brad go bright right pause
on all sides look at look at a cop
accomplish free solo Brad go right dies
in climbing accident their descent 3:30
p.m. hmm
what else does another climber fell two
guys fell damn with him free soloing man
that I mean it's just it's the what it's
your you're pushing you're just begging
the universe to try to try to make it
harder for you to stay around
I think climbing a rock without ropes is
just the wildest thing on earth oh yeah
I don't know much that's crazier that
free solo documentary saw that huh
creeped me out
it gave me the it made my chest feel
weird right because I was like this dude
is off his rocker he had zero regard for
the idea that he actually could go I
think it just didn't even never
registers to him that like death is a
thing that's real it just doesn't feel
like it is to him he's like no I'm gonna
know people die but I don't I'm not
gonna die what's the closest you ever
came to dying
honestly choked I was gonna say one time
I choked on a McNugget and I thought I
was gonna die I'm dead-ass serious I
choked on a McNugget where'd you get it
from Mickey D's but where though
remember what market out of McDonald's
on neighbor yeah in Chicago Chicago
downtown and the suburbs no in the
suburbs and at Shanae préval Woodridge
choked on a nugget mmm Ching I swear to
God I thought I was gonna die maybe
lodged in my throat no I was with a
buddy oh wow and he was I was like and
he was trying to do the Heimlich but
wasn't really working and I had I was
trying to force myself and it dislodged
somehow thank God but I thought for sure
that way I mean I've had a few moments
of like you know bad accident type of
stuff that freaked me out that gave me a
scare but it wasn't like I mean I had I
caught a I got a rebound when I was in
high school at an open gym game and a
guy took out my legs I fell on my neck
and I blacked out like four or five
times didn't break my neck though I
would I think the doctor said something
like I was a few pounds per square inch
of pressure from cracking my neck that
crazy this is the vertebra it was so
bruised and had so much swelling and
pressure from the liquid that like it
alone should have broke just to relieve
itself but it didn't I got lucky I was
blacking in and out of consciousness
when the paramedics were there and they
said it was a severe concussion mm-hmm I
felt it for like a week and a half dude
I don't know what those football players
go through in the NFL but falling on my
neck one time changed the way I played
basketball for ever I don't I never I
stopped jumping mmm I was like I'm never
jumping again scared scared me so much
man it was just it freaked me out I woke
up in the hospital three or four times
you throw up sometimes when you have a
concussion
you ever get one yeah yeah I got one of
my brothers I was looking for something
I fell down but I'm just max your head
yeah
just hit my head on something real hard
it like this weird angle coming down and
uh next thing you know I was like
talking to him didn't remember like
standing back up and sat down and then
did you throw up so I love it'll throw
her off she felt like I needed to take a
nap and what I was like right in this
middle like this conversation with it
was just really really very bizarre did
you have a near-death moment your life
you know I choked actually this was in
Chicago I choked on if I have Gatorade
and tuna fish at the same time I'll chip
my throat closes that's in your
Wikipedia page no it is I said me but
Gatorade and tuna fish yeah there's
something about the like that acid and
the what's in tuna fish that would make
you get fish shellfish I don't know if
fish oil fish but I have it and uh bro
and not and it happened once before and
I was like oh this is insane you know
you had tuna fish and Gatorade once
before and it just you did it again
and I was like oh this is just something
else is going on and you
maybe I can suck might be maybe I
stepped on something but um but this
time when it happened I was like oh [ __ ]
it's really is a thing I should have
learned the first time but this really
is
I like tempted it you know what color
Gatorade uh this was pink ooh pink
Gatorade could be why so I'm in a hotel
room in Chicago I'm having it you know
I'm running late I just went to the gym
excuse me but bless bless three three
blessed for always a three I'm a - you
are I'm a - only two Nick is it - I'm a
- yeah I gotta tighten up that third one
is like hey I'm what are you doing it's
a little much yeah it's like I bless you
bless you move and then when I when the
third one comes I go like this
last year I come a little tired of
saying bless you now at that point my
grandma does four or five yeah 14 years
ago risk it was a form of communication
back then it was flirting with someone
if you blessed him three times four
times you know you think she made
herself sneeze more oh she just sniff
sniff and dust all day just yours I have
someone have one sneeze and it's really
creepy and they don't sneeze again when
you get nervous right and they're like
graphic and they keep talking to you
you're like what was that like I just
sneeze
dude I had a friend who would close the
mouth sneeze out of his nose oh my god
[ __ ] Sava don't ever hold your breath
and sneeze you know that right don't
ever do that you blow an o-ring that way
I know the guy that did that yeah he you
know when you hold it in he did want to
sneeze out loud blue is blue his booty
we found we nor hurt scared
does your we do you get you have hot you
ski are you scared of heights I wouldn't
say that I'm scared of heights but I'm
not real fired up about him when you
look oh when I look over like a big
balcony mmm my penis feels weird do you
does that do that to anybody else one
I'll tell you why and you can if you
don't mind Google this as well not crazy
it's because you're Lively your life is
in your in my penis yeah but I don't
feel it in my longevity though but
you're that the thing of I'm gonna live
long I'm gonna have a child I'm going to
procreate all of that is my genitalia in
that area but it rattles through my
shaft it's like a it's like a rattler
yeah roaming through my chefs your
shafts like hey we have to procreate
round we need family yeah we not you're
not a bird
you know I'm saying your dicks trying to
let you know you're not a bird we need
family yeah stick around
don't jump that's what it's doing yeah
it makes me tingle in my in my penis
when I when I get mine Heights
it's that thing are you seeing something
there Nick a male that is afraid of
heights when they are in a ladder
peering over about can he do I get a
tingling sensation see look this is a
reddit thread someone was asking explain
like I'm five why this happens and
someone else had the funny thing is I
get that same tingling feeling when I'm
very excited about finishing a task I
completely understand that I get the
anxious I get anxious about when
something's about to come to a close my
balls tingle like when I end every set
when I get the light and stand up my
balls start to tingle like I know what's
coming to a close mm-hmm yeah it's weird
your balls are trying to stasis to say
stay safe and you have adrenaline
coursing through your veins your brain
is telling your body there may be danger
coming mm-hmm it's fight-or-flight
kicking in mm-hmm I'm fighting baby mmm
there's no flight in these nuts they are
trying to reach exit your body this is
your semen trying to egg you your body
to reach a safer place now that makes
sense well should I carry a cup I should
just put a bunch of semen in a cup when
that happens to save that that might be
the good stuff well this articles now
say freeze all your blood they say get
as much blood out of your body freeze it
somewhere get it in case you need it in
the future in case your kids need it in
case because otherwise you're taking
your kids on me like hey does anybody
have any [ __ ] put a stranger's blood
stranger blood when you're full of it
and you're like oh [ __ ] somebody oh I
got so much blood I have so much blood
no really I have too much blood doctors
told me I have too much blood i i i cut
i cut my gums on on a potato chip
habanero a habanero potato chip and I
bled for like a month and a half and one
of the doctor and he said you got too
much blood it's got to get out yeah it's
like really it was I was relieving some
of the pressure but I asked him if my
blood was worth anything and he pulled
me into a little tiny room and he said
me your blood is worth more than most
Americans you're in the 1% of the blood
club so I signed up for this thing I
have a card I have to go I have to go
see this you know person who test me
every every couple of weeks from the
from the government is it next health or
something
the health the health yeah the health
yeah so when you have too much blood
it's one of those things you think yeah
you get you got kind of you're I'm on a
new I'm on a new level dude we had a guy
remember that was choking one time when
I was young at school and two other guys
they were trying to do the Heimlich but
they didn't how to do it to other guys
held him one by his arms while my his
legs and some guy ran up and [ __ ]
kicked him dude he was choking on part
of a Twix or something yeah which one
the right or left which I hope my
choking on one of the side broke like
four of his ribs and saved his life dude
well that's it's worth it right I think
you I'm willing to break a couple of
ribs to save my life
someone said would you be would you be
willing to if okay if the greatest
singer of our generation hmm you know
was a blind kid who's this blind kid and
you either had to kill him or you die a
tragic death what would you do I'd kill
him you'd kill the kid
cuz he's blind no I'd kill him just as I
feel whatever it is to stay alive yeah
greatest singer of our of all of our
general Kim deal will get extra singers
to shitty singers I can learn how to
pipe it together you know we'll remix
some shitty guy with dreads would you
kill would you kill Nick to stay alive
yeah mmm would you kill Theo to stay
alive the greatest comic of our
generation probably not loyal
he knows who writes his checks actually
maybe I wouldn't kill you maybe I would
take my own life but I would make Nick
very very upset about it first I
wouldn't even think about it I'd kill
Nick so fast I would I'd kill him I
would be a little bit over two if I hit
him with my card you keep running him
over that just approved the universe
that I'm stumped sticking around I would
joke that yeah I'd have all right hang
you over a balcony I'd Vanilla Ice yet
where sugar night is there a black eye
named sugar night the sugars he has
diabetes the sugars night
the sugars night if you haven't all
these sweet I got a UH
before I forget so I'm choking on this
tune in this Gatorade I go to the
hallway I try to call the front desk I
can't even talk my my throat is closed
up I'm putting one of my hands down my
throat and trying to open my fingers to
keep my air
'we open because the problem is that i'm
allergic allergic yeah and so i my
throat is closed up to tuna right
yep tuna and Gatorade so
something-something the chemical
properties offset each other something
happened huh something in it yeah I mean
I just nothing else has ever done it to
me and then so next thing I know I'm in
the hallway and I'm trying to the
cleaning lady you know I'm just making
these sounds I remember she hands me a
tampon and she assumed it must mean had
a tampon thing in the car they gave me a
little pack that make sense like what
mannequins like you need tampon yes
that's exactly what that means that's
communicating I need a tampon
you know when you're in the hotel room
and the cleaning lady they come in they
knock and they come in right away do you
tell them right over to you oh no no I'm
good I'm good or do you let them figure
it out I let him figure it out I just
let him figure it out
I sit in bed and I let him come all the
way and then they go oh so sorry I'm
like that's okay that's okay I just let
him it's okay I'm just gonna get new
towels I let him in you're just sitting
there naked on the computer
come on in no that's right just towels
this right just sitting there typing
away but a snake I stay naked in a hotel
I stay naked oh dude there's something
about hotels a comedian used to do a bit
about it there's something about hotels
where you get in there you got to get
make you got a good name I don't know as
well cuz it's not your room you feel
naughty you're in somebody else's room
and you just you don't have any
responsibility if anything goes wrong in
there it's not your problem yeah it's
really nice it's like a rental that you
don't that there's no agreement on you
know what I mean a temporary rental that
if something happened you just like
that's not me I didn't do that that was
there when I came in yeah that's the
best part there's no responsibility in
hotels you could do whatever you want
you have as many people there it's
wonderful I know a girl in high school
they used to live in one of those
extended stay hotels she would have
parties every single day oh wow no
consequences and she was a real party
type of girl mm-hmm mm-hmm
and her mother was a her and a single
mother and her mother was never around
because she was working I never saw her
mom we got to go over that we gotta go
to the extended stay all the time and
just party it was wonderful man
you know anybody in high school who had
an apartment I didn't really I remember
this girl I asked her out one time she
said yes I took her to a dance and I had
a chance to like take off her underpants
one time and it was just me and her and
I [ __ ] uh scared
got nervous yeah what kind of with a
granny panties so hot I don't remember
you she was hot and you got nervous she
was so [ __ ] hot dude I was from when
the I remember going in the bathroom and
masturbating she the thought of maybe
taking off her pant that you the fact
that you didn't get to take off her
panties and she was still in the living
room and I did it yeah I get that trust
me I've done [ __ ] like that I just when
were sit on a pool table and I like kind
of had my hands like on the upper legs
and it was just feeling and we're
kissing bro and I was like [ __ ] dude I'm
living my dreams you know
and then I [ __ ] couldn't handle the
pressure you broke huh oh dude I don't
remember now I remember getting scared
was like I'm not gonna get an erection
everything this girl hates me you did
get an erection though I don't remember
and when I went in the bathroom but he's
easy to get an erection to masturbate
are you looking at yourself in the
mirror no I looked I only looked at
myself when I jerked off in the mirror
Yeah right into my eyes oh yeah all
right as I came oh I'd wink at myself ah
who are you bro [ __ ] day Hannibal
Lecter Rob are you that guy from who is
that guy on that movie that they do the
business cards where they kill American
Psycho yeah yeah that's exactly what
that is
the first hookup nur offs on him the
first hookup nerves are bad I went down
on a girl that I had such a big crush on
for so long that she tapped me on the
head to let me know that I was done like
I said like that's it that'll do I swear
to God I was so nervous made buddy this
ain't the swim team up I did I was so
nervous man she was so beautiful I never
thought you'd have sex with me and she
said I can't believe you didn't have sex
with me but I was nervous I thought she
would did - I know man my first year of
college I was so I was like this girl
doesn't have sex with me dude I remember
hooking up with this girl and I was
gonna lose my virginity and
how old were you mmm I don't remember 15
or 16 an action lose my virginity on a
bowling alley in our town shout out
Tiffany lanes over there on highway 22
Floyd
roll some stones while people are
throwing rocks at us speaking of stones
man really yeah just because they didn't
like their you got premarital sex just
excitement know people excitement and
they had rocks around them so when they
got amped up they're like we gotta hit
him with something cuz we're so happy
for him yeah where's cheering our boy on
it makes sense that's like why people
throw rice at weddings thing you're
excited so you wanna throw something at
him yeah big yeah you ever did you get
hit with a rock while you're getting
where you're hooking up oh I'm sure I
caught a couple nothing nothing nothing
big shells you know like those shells as
white shells people used to use his
driveway shells yeah that's what you got
here with yeah those don't hurt that
much huh
they're not real rocks no they're like
yeah I don't know what they are they're
not really known that they're like half
Hollow yeah it's kind of like rocks for
poor people kind of poor rocks you know
the same poor people always had those
shell driveways and always for some
reason and they were all and it was
always a mess it was always as was oil
stains all over it there was tons of
Tyre chunks if someone had spun out in
the winter and left it like that
oh never those those like oh my god yeah
it'll bitty shell yeah they were like
yeah poor rocks poor people but this
girl uh dude I remember hooking up and
and then I ended up Jack you late and
early you know so we didn't engage and
then uh I was so like nervous for some
reason that everybody at the party would
know I made both of us climb out of the
window and come in through the front
door of our of my house to the party
they knew you were upstairs and then you
left and came back in I think I was just
I just didn't want anybody like knowing
my business I guess I was like oh if
people see us come out of this bedroom
together but if they saw you coming to
the front door when they thought you
went upstairs then they you think that
was more normally think maybe we were
magic but not [ __ ] yeah yeah they
think you're special to have special
talents yeah they like damn these people
are mad what were they doing up there
transporting reincarnating by the front
door himself but no it was first Oh his
first floor window so it was just but
there was a bunch of bushes out there
hurt being like my climb and how do you
what did you tell you that people can't
know yeah I was just like oh we should
probably keep this on the DL it's more
fun this way yeah and maybe it's cuz me
yeah it could have been more fun it
could I don't remember it's adventurous
right when you're young you're more
adventurous with where you'll have more
adventure at anywhere you'll do it
anywhere you'll hide in more fun places
yeah yeah we were like first of all set
a car sexes high school car sex was such
like a common thing you had to have sex
in the car yeah where else you gonna go
I mean we have basements in the Midwest
so people go to the basements oh yeah
there you go man you go in a basement
somebody somebody had a cool everybody
had a cool basement like where you could
you could sneak away in a corner the
basement and get away with it but car
sex was everything for some reason and
you'd find the darkest deepest corner of
your community and a cop would somehow
roll back yeah why because you're just
as dumb as a [ __ ] you're just as dumb
at the time you're just a dumb kid you
picked the easy spot yeah but you think
it's smart you think it's great and
counts have already been kids so they're
like oh this is a place I would go there
like this were right Yeah right behind
the church or right behind just
someplace that's like you're caught
having sex um my mother caught me
getting a [ __ ] Oh a girl's the same
girl that may climb out that window
mm-hmm we tried to have sex at her house
one time and the mom came in the room
and I went over and introduced myself
cuz I didn't know what else to do you
know stick out oh yeah she throw rocks
too mom comes she didn't look at my dick
though and I did respect that she did
not know she just stared at your eyes
the whole time yep and I'm never gonna
knew that this lady's a good lady yeah
what about you knit kind of just
recently so it was the girls staying at
her parents and I had to introduce
myself to her mother she was like 28
years old but state living at home
because what a minute so you did you get
they caught you in the act at all or no
she just knew you were there pie came
home came over at like 3:00 a.m.
don't you look don't don't why couldn't
she come to you my place is kind of
shitty I'm always down to go someplace
else
she lives in Orange County she's got a
nice crib what do you like outcalls
growin and like a three-person
apartments it was a three-person house
her mom and dad and they knew you were
that yeah they did 3:00 a.m. yeah you
couldn't just be post mates and
yeah Wow was it it was it but as you
start doing we start wearing postmates
shirts or over shirts she she was
Filipinos like you know Jo koy I used to
work for Jo koy he said that yeah she
loved it huh oh yeah she's like we love
jo koy he is a hundred percent
penetration that community he's like we
love jo koy I know you want me to call
him on my phone right now
jo help me get out of this please what
did you say to the mother what did you
what was the first thing you said I was
I like introduced myself right cuz you
weren't Nikki yours over yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and Shane and I just gotten in
and she was like what's all the
commotion and stuff yeah we weren't
engaged did you still hook up yeah yeah
good for you after you met the mother
before yeah she brass cakes I know jo
koy man that's perfect that's very smart
and a good fan and by the way good for
her go for the mother being cool about
it she didn't kick you out you seem like
a nice kid you're tall too boy she
probably could feel that in your bones
hmm and she was like you stick around
bud yeah you're a good you're a good
white kid from from the Midwest she
could feel it I mean the girls 28 she
gonna have gas it's not like right it's
not like your children now that's a
unique thing too I remember going
somewhere with my mom and my stepdad and
meeting a lady that worked at this
restaurant and then that night the next
morning I tell my mom mom member the
girl from the restaurant she's in the
room and my mom was like why like it
just like magic you know like yeah what
do you do magic you know like November
we went out I said I'm just smelling
like tequila just bad you know mm-hmm
and just like I had this old mother had
this old bed we do hooked up on her like
these Mardi Gras beads hanging off of it
yeah better hanging off of it
that's just like anybody from Louisiana
with no money you would decorate show
Mardi Gras they were cheap yeah yeah
they're cheap and they look pretty nice
from far away that the light shiny yes
color a little bit of color yeah it
always looks festive dude but they are
just so loud if you're trying to engage
with somebody in you're trying to tickle
somebody or have sex and uh and that
blew my mind was March like you have to
sneak her
here if your stepdad Cesar mm yeah
stepdad wouldn't approve yeah he was
kind of a curmudgeon Ethan when I some
people don't want to approve anything
you know Ria's that what he was like he
was just attitude about everything
didn't like anything mmm I think well in
his home you know I think men get that
way at a certain point and I get it you
know oh we don't do that stuff in my
home I paid I you get you want it you
want to do that go to go get your own
house yeah that's that old phrase like
it says mine if you want to do something
you go get your own yeah I get that I
get that I'm you know if I have kids and
there's always that awkward point when
your son starts masturbating and oh I'm
gonna make him do it outside you can't
do that in my house you have to step
outside well my dad used to make us bury
it do it if he we'd your thought he'll
put it in yeah go put in the art I'm
gonna build a masturbation Chet I say
you go to the shed and put a little baby
heater in there for when it's cold you
know but go to the shed I want you to go
to the shed and think about it oh that's
lovely
yeah go jerk off in the shed let it stay
out it outside of my home I paid for the
home I make them buy the shed right and
it'll give them sort of an idea of like
okay you know this is something this is
a special event uh-huh not you dish can
when you think sometimes wouldn't you
know the the product of human that's
being created these days it's like no
wonder yeah I don't want everybody has
some you know some kid has nine elbows
and he [ __ ] you know and he's just
drinking snot out of his nose no [ __ ]
wonder because every decent nut was
ejaculated all gone yeah it's all so low
now the leftovers these are the nuttier
you're from nut 9,000 don't want a
[ __ ] honey of six tongs dude and
you're never gonna be able to read yeah
it's a beautiful day I'm happy you're
here and I'm happy I'm here what I'm
saying is that some men suffer from
erectile difficulty and that's problems
within your body by your penis and this
episode is sponsored by blue Chu
remember the days when you were always
ready to go do you remember that guys
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
listen up
blue chewed calm that's blue like the
color blue blue to brings you the first
chewable erectile helper
with the same fda-approved active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis you can
pop them anywhere day or night afternoon
leap year even on a full stomach
and they work up to twice as fast as a
swallowable pill blue chew is prescribed
online by licensed physician so you
don't go to the doctor office or wait in
the line at the pharmacy it ships right
to your door in a discreet packaging oh
I wonder what that is maybe a new maybe
a new hammock nah player test them
poppers they're made in the USA and
since blue chip repairs and ships direct
they're cheaper than a pharmacy right
now I got a special deal for the
listeners of this podcast go to blue
chicom and get your first shipment free
when you use our code
théo just pay five dollars shipping ooh
excuse me I had a couple and I'm ready
just pay five dollars shipping again
that's BL you eche w.com
promo code th EO to try it for free blue
chew is the better cheaper faster choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
podcast and once your penis is doing
well you can tighten up the rest to
yourself I'm talking about manscaped
support for this past weekend comes from
manscaped who is the best in men below
the belt
grooming manscape offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
a lot of times you'll see somebody's
penis and you don't know what's going on
with it or you'll see somebody will have
you know a bunch of junk lying around
their their car but times have changed
and you can tighten up your penis and
everything all your hair on your body
it's time to gear up and get yourself
the gift of Shaving this holiday season
I'm talking about the manscaped perk
perfect package 2.0 man a lot of people
will accidentally cut into their scrotum
when they're trying to trim their hair
on their body not you
why the revolutionary company manscaped
has redesigned the electric trimmer
their lawnmower 2.0 has proprietary
advanced skin safe technology you'll
never Nick you're nuts tis the season to
get manscape for yourself or someone
else get 20% off and free shipping with
code theo at manscaped comm your balls
will thank you get 20% off in free
shipping with codes theo at manscape
dot-com clean up your nuts and make
everyone proud and now back to the
program let's get a question we had some
we had some video questions that came in
oh why did humans man look at this guy
it
what's up Theo I wanted to know how do
you guys manage anger it could be
somebody making you angry or you're
angry at something and how do you
respond to it and how you stay cool in
gang Umbra and you go yeah let's start
you I like that guy
I like that you're more of an anger guy
I'm very angry off no but I'm a balanced
guy I just I have anger in me I like
that guy because he I knew he was gonna
be have a foreign accent but I I knew I
wouldn't know where it was from it was
just a little tinge of something he's
got a little Eastern European and there
or something like that plate plate plate
plate what's up man what's up man is
somebody making you angry or you're
angry at something and how do you
respond to it and how you stay cool yeah
he's a tinge of something over something
: Eastern European
I'm gonna go Poland I'm also gonna say
he's from Canada though do you know he's
from debt he didn't say okay he's from
Newfoundland defend it's a Newfoundland
how do I manage anger I think everyone
does it I mean on a personal level
obviously I I like to run I put on
headphones and I run for as long as I
can until negative thoughts go away Wow
I get no fight with the old bag I put on
my headphones and I disappear into the
night running at nights like my favorite
thing in the world to get rid of like my
anxiety or my anger I just run until I
feel like I'm done I Forrest Gump it for
real I just run until I'm done I know
exactly when I'm done it's not like a
number saying it sound like a mileage
ticker I just keep running and then
sometimes one time I ran so far I took a
goober home damn around seven miles in
one direction and I was like I don't
want to run seven miles back yeah
fuckin'-a to uber sometimes I do that
[ __ ] that's how I manage it I used to
tell I you know therapy and all that
stuff you can do a lot of that too but I
find exercise for some reason it wipes
away all the thoughts in my brain yeah
negative [ __ ] someone's being negative
and it's am circulating in my world you
know people being mean or rude or
whatever I just I just run well having
that physical element you have feels it
it's so imperative really I think in
anything is having a physical element to
go along with whatever your process is
program is like you know you see a lot
of these guys you see a lot of guys who
you know in that in the self-help world
a lot of them have a real physical
element also to what they do the first
rhythm active keeps your blood moving
mind you that you're like a being that
is not just this brain that's just like
you know stuck on this you know in a
weird little rabbit wheel or whatever
yeah that you are this this this you
know capable creature you know and it
reminds your body that and I think your
body even reminds your brain that and
like on another level I do chill the
[ __ ] out but good thing about that [ __ ]
were running bro yeah we're doing look
how capable you are yeah you you do yoga
right you still do yoga I've been doing
actually recently I've gotten into a lot
of meditation recently which has really
been helping me feel good and uh and
yeah I do yoga and I go to the gym I get
I have a trainer now that I go see at
least two days a week and then I'll go
by myself too and it helps manage it
yeah it's just these days you gotta have
it were more sedentary creatures out
them hmm it's well it's easier to get
everything you know you have it
delivered you sit in your car you sit
around too much we work at these things
sometime you know what I mean you do
podcast a lot like you're sitting and
operating working on computers and
things all the time
yeah you have to get up and go what how
do you what do you do what do you do to
manage your anger you work out is that
what you do - well meditation helps me
and then you're not an angry guy most of
my angers at myself really yeah I don't
see you get angry at other things other
elements you don't really get mad at it
you're a hard guy as long as I've known
you I've never seen you get really angry
at somebody unless they really did
something bad but it's rare for you to
get upset yeah I think I think it for
some reason I just end up hating to be
getting upset at myself you know so like
so these days is just kind of managing
that realizing that things are okay and
if I have anger realized and figuring
out what my part is in it why am i angry
at this person like what's really going
on am I really angry at this person or I
probably could have done something a lot
of times I didn't communicate here
clearly that's a lot of my problem I
noticed I don't communicate clearly what
I want in the beginning or what I'm
hoping for what I'm expecting so then I
get down the road and it's like what the
[ __ ] going on dude right now I'm
saying what did you expect a word of
Carnival dude don't say I'm right I'm
trying to buy quikrete dog and you and
me or [ __ ] eating Sundays at our
carnival yes it's pissing me off
[ __ ]
it's like well dude I didn't know you
know so a lot of times for me I noticed
his communication that's where things
get yeah it is Aaron because the story
will go in my head yeah my head will
start rattling but yeah I'll do some
meditation and uh my physical fitness
always helps let's get into another one
here we got the og toe what up guys this
is uh Beckett from Colorado so about a
week ago is on this first date with this
beautiful girl and she wears a margarita
right and I worded a nice glass of milk
and she didn't want a second date so I
guess my question to y'all is uh adults
drinking milk your name what do you guys
think yeah
gang gang chug chug chug chug yeah yay
oh yay do that that's dope a guy wants a
glass of milk he's an adult you can have
a glass of milk is the greatest country
on Earth
you know they don't let you have milk in
certain countries that's true
it's a great country can just have milk
it maybe he didn't want a margarita I
don't you don't need her bro she doesn't
need to be judging your liquid choices
that's insane
yeah the only liquids you should keep
away from Theo or pink Gatorade if he's
eating yeah that's a no-no I don't like
that she's maybe he didn't feel like
having a drink
there's that's something weird about you
know going on dates that I hear from all
my friends are like they go on dates and
it's like are they gonna have is it
gonna be an alcoholic beverage or not
that's always like a bodacious yeah you
got to make that choice yeah and and it
shouldn't even be a it shouldn't even
matter if you're gonna go have drinks
you just we'll talk about it after the
dinner and the drinks yeah and I mean
the dinner and the date the date it's
like if we want to go to a bar if that's
the next step but I don't think my boy
from Colorado should feel bad about
having a glass of milk especially if it
was you know farm-fresh you know I mean
yeah I think it and hopefully you went
whole milk if you go a skim milk when
shorter so that's probably abut well
that could have been it maybe she was
probably like he's like I'll just take a
1% and she was like oh boy I think get
out of here we don't need dessert though
or if he asked for some weird-ass milk
he didn't say he didn't it could have
been goats yeah if you ever go Charlotte
breasts if you ask for anything real out
ostentatious bro I think that's a bit
much dude I think if you order milk
though at a bar I think it is
it's not gonna give her the air that you
are probably living alone you know yeah
but can I tell you something
milk at a bar such a bold choice that it
makes me think you're an adventurous
dude that's a good point but he at his
age I wonder yeah
at his age I just seems like yeah but he
said but he said he said at dinner so it
wasn't at a bar I think it was at a
restaurant okay they went to a nice
restaurant that's legit I met milk with
my meal
yeah respect man you [ __ ] drink what
you want exactly yeah a lot of times I
let the lady order first that way if she
wants alcohol she can have alcohol and
then I'll then I'll order after you know
or if I get there early I'll order
something if I'm worried about how she
if drinking or not I'll get something
like a seltzer water put a lime in it
I'll get a non-alcoholic beer sometimes
if I really want you like the taste of
those there's so many of them now oh
there are wow there's like ten different
ones I didn't even know that yeah I know
I know oh do Liz the one that I my
buddies the duals the most popular he
drinks that all the time he'll uh he'll
rip through 12 he would rip a rip some
dude it's he'll get a 12-pack and be
like in an hour
like I gotta borrow doles I love that
tune I think I think that's it
hey I don't I've never had one so I
don't I don't the flavor is good
yeah the flavor is good and the new ones
are they have ones that are a lot more
exquisite now oh you know what I'm lying
I row ghen has the Heineken does one
what is it called yeah zero zero or I
don't remember the name
whatever Rogan maybe try one wants but
it but I don't like Heineken mmm so yeah
I didn't taste I was just like no this
is not it taste like Heineken sign it
was and Heineken a lot of black man
drink Hynek and you know it yeah black
guys like like males beer yeah yeah like
men drink black guys don't like IPAs
that's a white guy beer IPA is white
black guys like clear beer yeah your
beer I don't know what that is I don't
like I don't like Heineken for some
reason I just can't do it honey can
always gave me like a headache and stuff
remember when I was in high school there
was always something weird about it yeah
no I I threw it threw me for a loop but
also I think like when you were saying
what you do to order in advance I think
that's really smart
that you ordered like a seltzer water
just to like set the tone yeah and if I
put a lineman that she doesn't know what
it is that way it's like if if in her
mom
you know and also if you don't drink in
this I feel like sometimes if you don't
there's no pressure for the girl to
drink I'm also not at the I'm not at the
place in my life where I'm trying to
take home a drunk girl you know she's a
lot of work huh it's work it's risky I
feel like you know it's it just yeah and
it just it's I don't know it's just not
what I'm into really I don't want
sometimes drunk person I want years and
years ago some drunk girl want thought
she was at a [ __ ] mall or something
wandering her my apartment picking up
stuff looking at the bottom of it for
prices she's like there's no prices on
anything what did she buy any does she
get like it's my [ __ ] apartment you
know I'm saying like a soda charged her
she picked up someone like 2385 but I
give it to you for 24 24 how about that
I'll give you I'll go up in price when I
used to go on dates I would just eat the
full meal before they even ordered oh
yeah yeah i order in advance I would eat
it while there look at the venue just to
set the tone you know it's like I get to
eat then you get to eat I'm ready to go
I'm ready I gotta get out of here I eat
dessert when they're getting their me it
needs to only invite chicks to the
movies it was cold and I would go in
early so they had to get their ticket
show you like you're warming up you're
halfway through the popcorn genius
and I said girls honey probably one girl
yeah that's it that worked one time I
think that guy whose milk just go back
to it quickly she'd do it every time
that's a great weeding out process the
guy likes milk if she's not cool with
that she's not the one yeah exactly
imagine meeting the girl that goes I'll
take a milk too
he's like this is my wife oh yeah that's
a commercial for milk Dairy Farmers of
America she like milk you ought to like
her
here's a beautiful guy check him from
England got one question for you who
would be the better father CEO Andrew or
Bobby Lee baby gang gang gang gang who
would be the better father is that
really sent in the better father
[ __ ] he says father lover who would be
the better father
let me ask you to put down for yo who
would be a better father I like the way
they say stuff Oh would be it but it's
like they're all allowed to have a lisp
yeah who would be the better father you
know I mean that they get away with it
if a English guy's a lisp it sounds
cooler for some reason oh yeah when it
when it when I like an American head
when he's back lift yeah he always like
no yes
up here stuff these are my favorites in
here oh we don't fart of this it's just
something that we have to focus on yeah
I know a girl who dated a guy with four
s's in his first and first and last name
ah she had a say you should call him
that all the time
oh uh who would be the better father
oh god of us three of me you and Bob I
don't know man I think we'd all make
decent fathers in her own right no
that's not true
I think you and me would we'd have a
better a better shot yeah Bobby would
not be he wouldn't be a bad dad I think
he would just um he'd be a bad
stepfather a terrible stepfather he'd be
a good he'd be a good friend of your
friend of your dad's yeah like a buddy a
hangout buddy you and I be great day you
be a great father man you used to have a
lot of you have so much whimsy I think
kids need an adult who has whimsy do you
know what I mean yeah you know there's a
comic out of Philadelphia at Crystal
Connor he's hilarious he's so funny and
he said that about somebody a family
member he goes the dude lacks all whimsy
it made me laugh I was like wow that's
so you need to have whimsy when you're a
father figure because kids they it can
go anywhere
yeah like let him let him do it let him
fly dude they're in the wind they're
figuring it all out yeah they don't even
know what's going on think about dude
nobody remembers eight years old who
[ __ ] knows I'm no idea the stuff that
you got into whenever you watch I was
watching kids on the plane these two
little boys were sitting next to us um
we came back and they were losing
having so much fun they were throwing
M&Ms at each other and he was like he's
like he's like throw it in my mouth and
he would on purpose throw it hit him in
the eye and he would laugh and he's like
do it again he knew it was coming again
it was great they made a bunch of little
games with little M&Ms and the man next
to them wasn't enjoying he had zero
whimsy he didn't like it he didn't like
it I say he should have been like throw
it give me one you know I mean he's yeah
play along
get the pickup ask for the throw you
know throw me the ball I always do that
I have enough whimsy in me where I'm I'm
excited about a little a little person
too
I want to hear what they what they're
thinking about yeah whenever I see
little little people I'm gonna talk
about like Brad Williams talking about
oh yeah yeah yeah cuz I know what he's
thinking about little freak
threesomes and all of that well freak
he's into the dark arts many not really
his man he really no I just I think
about I just want to know what's going
through their little heads cuz they're
yeah they're fit they're filled with all
sorts of weird fun ideas the stuff that
they come up with and they get there but
dude my nephew just got his butt out
this time when I was it and we kept
showing it out like the coolest thing
he'd ever got it is though cuz he just
found us found it imagine how fun that
is when you just fatherhood imagine you
just saw now that you had hands you know
I mean like look at you show with
everybody how old is your nephew he 107
and one you got five I got two or six
and four yeah I got two Wow I got well I
got two little nieces and they're like
they're incredible we went to Harry
Potter town with them really they came
out here yeah a wiry Potter land at
Universal yeah it's cool bro it's so fun
yeah I was like this is gonna be good
for the girls I was loving it yeah I had
three butterbeers I was living my life
dude I thought ice for real I was like
this week I was excited for the girls
but then when I got there I was excited
for me yeah it was what it's so fun to
live in that world you're like this is
what they experience all the time
this kind of this kind of thought
process is how they're living every day
yeah I wish we could have more of that
yeah there's more possibility there's
not as much judgement yeah the rule the
rules are less the rules are like don't
hit don't be mean enjoy
yeah but the rules are less there's more
like openness to to creativity and then
adult world there's almost none
I mean outside of what we do for a
living I'm saying in your regular life
you can't be that you're not allowed to
kind of you get bogged down yeah well
people don't like you to stretch they
don't like they want people in order
everybody likes order you know I mean
yeah they just want it to be very
organized it's kind of fun with it
that's why Southwest Airlines makes me
laugh when they're you know yeah if you
go into Vegas to come back to Vegas they
always do it right yeah they just figure
it out yeah yeah I love that it's kind
of chaotic the only airline lets people
wear short they were short their own
shirts you know I mean I saw dude with
his own company name on his shirt my own
brand yeah I was like they don't really
does it right dude and they're like yeah
that fly doesn't seem like they'll
[ __ ] they're not that hot maybe but
they definitely seem like they'll [ __ ]
you don't call me will ya yeah they'll
come home they'll give you a ride home
if you ask yeah if I didn't jump my car
the other one let's go man I need a
jumpy saying I got you baby
what was that gentleman asking about
Nick he asked he said who the young
fella a better fighter oh yeah better
father I think that's it then I think
we'd probably maybe tie somewhere in
there yeah you'd be good at it man we
just know that Bobby be bad I think yeah
so bad and he would admit it oh my god
yeah he would leave it everywhere he
would leave kids he's a little baby he's
still gestating dude he sleeps almost as
much as a lot of those you know in utero
baby right well you know cuz he's so
round that he can he can lean on his
side now he doesn't even need to go down
he can just just a couple inches to the
left and now he's sleeping it's
incredible it's it's incredible to watch
he's a remarkable little tree you got
another one yeah let's hit another one
here we got a guy right here Oh
beautiful young minion CEO gang gang
Andrew I've got a question for you
why'd you next special I want to see I
want to see something man
I got Amazon Prime just so I can watch
your [ __ ] from like 27 years ago and I
feel like a stalker at this point I've
seen it like 10 times
that's very cool I appreciate that yeah
I don't know man um that's funny that's
funny because I you and I have kind of
talked about that and I wanna I want to
really talk to you for real about that
of like what are you gonna do next
because you and I for the path
couple years have talked about the state
of that in the state of comedy I don't
know what I want to do next as far as
the special goes I do want to put
something out but I read this article
that Jay Leno maybe was Holly report or
something and they asked him why he
doesn't do a special on Netflix they're
like all your friends are doing specials
like why don't you do one and he was
like I really love live comedy I want
people to come see me and and he's like
I don't really care about putting
something down forever
now Grant said that's not my opinion but
it struck a chord with me and I was like
me too though I love live shows I think
where you see it
I just love live shows I look I want
people to come see me when I come to
their town so bad it's not that I don't
want to put out a special but I'm like I
don't know I think part of the beauty
for me of stand-up is that we get to
keep changing over time and molding and
anybody who see me knows I tried to do a
lot of different stuff if I can you know
and change it up I mean I'm doing an
hour now that's kind of a thing but I
don't know man I just don't know what I
want to do me Netflix is I'm not really
on that ship you know I'm not really on
that boat you know no hate on them but I
don't think they yeah we have to get
offered well first of all if you want to
do it smell so you have to get offered
yeah yeah they we have to get an offer
from a place that also an offer that we
agree to where that's the other thing
you have to want to do it with them and
you have to be cool with the terms so
that's the thing that people don't know
unless you do it on your own which a lot
of people are doing but my fear of
putting one out on my own is I just
don't I don't know man you know like
Alan kind of went his own way you know
Schultz did his own thing there's a lot
of guys doing their own thing but for
the most part right now like I'm
comfortable in this pocket of I want I
want people to come see me live yeah the
beauty is live the beauty of it is live
it never stands up when you see
something I don't think on live you know
or see it whatever that's called on tape
but I appreciate that kind of love I
mean what like what like you I haven't
asked you know we haven't talked a long
time about that yeah what are you gonna
what are you gonna do oh I don't know I
got you know I know there's some
companies that have them you know
platforms that happen that are gonna
come see me
next week I got a server at The Wiltern
so they're gonna come see me and then
which you're gonna murder what a venue
to the wheel turns beautiful yeah I
never
I'm excited that's it's you've never
been inside uh-huh you're gonna bro it's
such a cool venue really gorgeous man
that was my first concert I ever saw or
the first band I saw in Los Angeles with
it was at the will turn into in it's
stunning man that they did such a
beautiful job with that man something
about those theaters that have history
in them that have been around for a long
time they feel like off that core so
yeah like I feel like they've got this
energy trapped inside of it oh man
you're gonna rip that's gonna be so
[ __ ] cool yeah should be yeah so I'm
excited I'm definitely excited about it
I feel you know stoked oh there's a
picture oh wow how beautiful that is
problem look at the ceiling of the will
turn it to me it's one of the coolest
venues I've seen stunning sorry to
interrupt the combo here with the red
rocket but I gotta let you know about
this gift opportunity I'm talking about
Ridge wallet tree the ridge wallet
it's that front pocket carry so you'll
see sometime a man will have on a
backpack or some luggage or a lot of
times even tape drugs to his legs and
run into the country but everything's
changed now with the new Ridge wallet
you keep the items you really need your
credit cards maybe a little bit of cash
your identification you know maybe a
birth certificate or social security
card keep them in that front pocket I'm
talking about the ridge it's super
durable made from military-grade
materials like titanium and carbon fiber
it's proven to be bulletproof
waterproof and chainsaw proof see
exactly how it works by going to ridge
comm slash Theo
that's our idge dot-com slash th EO and
use code Theo for 10% off link in
description ridge comm slash Theo I mean
the other one that was cool
Rogen took me to where were we Detroit
I mean Atlanta no we were in Cleveland
or Detroit one of those two Masonic it
was so beautiful I don't know what it
was but good god man we took a bunch of
photos of it I blew my mind how pretty
the art was yeah likely like the texture
of the ceiling stuff like that is what
really there's something about that you
know
oh yeah yeah there's something well it's
more it shows like okay this is joy
Detroit sorry yeah this is the art that
I'm doing film or is it
type that in you're so good with the
names of these play I'm so glad I doing
bigger places no no that's it that's it
nice that was it
unbelievable yeah that's beautiful was
stunned we kept takin a bunch of
pictures because I we I had never seen
something like that you know like with
him we'd performed in identies and
arenas are the ugliest looking for
things on earth yeah there's nothing
cool sexy about an arena it's so funny
the more that I've done with him the
more I'm like man this is it's just
rafters it's just like it's it's
wonderful to do it's just when you go in
a theater you look at the art that it's
involved on the inside and something
about the experiments I think his man is
beautiful gonna riff The Wiltern they're
gonna come see you and then would you
maybe put this out were you doing right
now on and a special yeah and so maybe I
will put something out it depends on
what time slots they have available for
like different platforms like you know
if they have something next year so then
it's like I don't want to hold material
for like a whole year yep so once I put
it out yeah and the certain point I want
to put it out you know certain point I'm
you know I'd like to just get it out
there and get it off my get it out of
out of me yeah so so then I would either
I don't know I thought about maybe just
making it and putting it on to I you
know a place to sell other than that
like other than Netflix so like iTunes
or you know or I thought about just
putting clips just making it into the
actual clip [ __ ] is that too and putting
it on to YouTube and then just also
putting out an album with it you know
and then I still own it so that's
another that's the other side of it is
also then you still have ownership of it
yeah the business side is the thing that
people don't really know about what we
have to operate in that regard it's a
lot more convoluted than just kind of
like do it do you John Baldessari is an
artist john baldessari
he did this thing where he just got kind
of inundated with like his ideas of what
he was making art wise and then he
burned all of it burned all of his art
just like start again and I had this
kind of like in the middle of the night
half lucid dream in and out where I
thought it'd be wild for me to shoot
something my on my own cheap and not
cost a production company lot of my like
I'll pay for it
and
put it out for 24 hours for one day and
then it goes away forever yeah I thought
about doing that I was like that would
be really fun and get all my friends to
promote it so it's like a man you can
only see it now like you want to watch
you have to watch it in this 24 hour
span and then it's gone I'd be gangster
yeah
yeah I thought I thought I was like that
could be really cool and then I can
retire in the material and then it can
kind of be this wonderful meta industry
thing where it's like if you saw it you
saw and if you didn't you did it now I
don't know if I'm gonna do it but I keep
having freshing feelings yeah there's
some gangster about being like naama do
it how I want to do it yeah because
there's it's so much out there now and
also taking it to see it live also
there's a lot of beauty in that because
like oh that's where you see it you see
it live I want you to see it in the way
that it's supposed to be singing yeah
it's hard when you put it on tape you
know like I heard somebody told me Ali
Wong just got Netflix just gave her
eight figures to do two more specials or
like a special on something else and I
was like God man the growth of that
thing is just as a big big big beast you
know so I'm like maybe something
alternative would be cool for me I don't
just for me so yeah maybe but I don't
know tell the the-the-the Theo fans let
me know if that would be something you'd
watch get in the 24 hour span or some
people might be like that's so annoying
I don't want to watch it that day and I
mean it's super interesting it's
different yeah I keep having this dream
about it it's like in the shower I think
about it all the time I'm like people
are you know I can already hear agents
and managers and lawyers like why would
you do that
yeah oh yeah that's how they think I
know but I just think it'd be fun like
cuz they sell it that's where they make
their month's money yeah but for us it's
like I want to make money on live shows
I want to engage with fans to come watch
us do our thing and that's how I want to
earn a living not like I'm saying there
you know I don't want to live in from
specials on that live on but something
neat about it going away I don't know I
don't know why I don't know there's
something about well I think over I
think it makes things everything now is
so accessible yes that's that's part of
the reason it's like how do you be
unique then would it be unaccessible
yeah you know it's kind of like but then
you risk the raw the run the risk of
being not not accessible right yeah
that's it yeah
but isn't that kind of the fun of it all
is like because we're so accessible
could it be cool to be
the only way you can see him is to go
see him you want to see his new stuff
you have to go see it yeah that'd be
kind of fun yeah that'd be kind of fun
of me but I don't want to say a joke
that you do because I know that's a it's
a that's a no-no but you did a joke last
night that made me laugh so hard I
walked outside I'm not I'm not kidding
oh thanks I lost my [ __ ] I never heard
you do it cuz it must be relatively new
hmm but it made me laugh so so hard I
walked outside I was in the hallway lat
dying laughing just just that I don't
want to say it but God man I wish I
could
it was so goddamn funny so I think I
hope you're that at The Wiltern I hope
that that blows right man I hope that
blows up and all those people want to
claw you and then you decide how you
want to do it that's the thing the fans
don't know we ultimately have to decide
how and when and why you want to do it
yeah and then you start to get tested by
your own stuff like am i doing this for
money am i doing this for you know what
am I doing this and do I really like
this stuff I'm putting out there's a
hard thing it's like do I love this
stuff or do I like this stuff yeah
because then you get caught in that rat
race of like everyone's like doing a
special year especially your especially
your special and then it's like how much
that stuff do they enjoy are you keeping
up with the Joneses or are you putting
out content that you really really love
that's like where it gets into this
weird gray area of like comedy and
business you know and doing that balance
yeah I used to like better being just a
comedian and not having to be business
you know and not having to do business
you know it's exhausting I'm gonna give
you a compliment real fast there's me
being very genuine now I've known you
for quite a long time we've been friends
for a long time and watching the growth
of you as a stand-up and as a comedian
it's it's wild it's like makes you real
feel proud proud is like a shitty word
it makes it sound like a it sounds kind
of sending for some reason but it's like
a it's like a pride in friendship
because I remember watching you in the
o.r a couple years ago maybe three maybe
four three or four and I was watching
you and I was thinking when the world
figures it out when they get it they're
gonna get it get it he's like I just I
was like when the world figures out how
good you were I was like it's gonna it's
all gonna take place and then to watch
it happen was very cool so as a friend
it was cool to watch thanks and I mean
that like it's a it's a weird thing to
see I don't think people it's hard to
describe it's almost like if for people
at home it's like if you
knew an athlete when you were young that
was so good and at your high school and
you were like this ridiculous and then
you actually see them progress on to
college or pro or whatever yeah it's
like everyone knows what you already
know it's a cool feeling you know it's
like I saw the band first type of [ __ ]
yeah it's a cool feeling you know
there's something about it that's that's
we only it only happened so many times
in our lives so yeah anyway that's how I
just I want to say that - because I just
thanks bro I was thinking about that
last night when I was when I we were
hanging out and watching you cuz you
know we get to be in the bed of it all
so while being at that club Bert with
the shirt off trying so good last night
oh my god last night the colliculus it
was laughing so hard at birth dude and
it was so funny because I hadn't
expected thank you for the nice words
man it's really nice yeah you know a lot
of - you know all I mean you know a lot
of us has been because of the podcast a
lot of people have you know we finally
get to connect yeah that's what this is
we finally after all this all this time
get to connect because when you used to
do Conan or The Tonight Show they didn't
know who you were so we would fist fight
to get on the air and then and then
those things never gave you an
opportunity to be you you didn't get to
be Theo yeah well it kept getting every
time I would submit to a Late Show they
would say oh you can't do this joke you
can't do this word you can't do it like
this
and it was like oh I'm not even I can't
be myself then I can't be I'm not a
commit you know I'm myself I'm a
comedian yeah but I'm also a person you
but they don't spend there's not and
there's some difference between the two
but there's not a ton of difference a
lot of times for me you know no you you
are you are a hyperbolized version of
this thing that that that you've created
this wonderful comedian character it's
like a microcosm of you and it's it's
the picture it's a bigger picture of it
all yeah right and why do you took it
personal when they said no you know and
I'm not student taking a personal you
said oh that's their business and maybe
I didn't take it personal maybe I just
said that's their business
and then I mean i reaiiy used to take it
personal it hurt it hurts your feelings
when they say no yeah you're like wait I
am good though and they just don't
there's just a missing something's not
connecting that's all but the thing
about this that you get to you get to
connect more on your own personal level
then yeah
fine I'll just do it my way you know
yeah and it's been definitely it's been
a it's been an amazing adventure man so
many just people that call in every week
and have like sharing their own stories
and it's been a journey brah and it's
been a journey going through just you
know it's been highs and lows like you
said man it's been highs and lows you
know I'm gonna continue to be that way
yeah just like I you know and in you
know just like on these these these
interviews sitting with friends and and
talk and it's like some sometimes on a
podcast I connect so much more with
people and sometimes you don't and it's
hard because the fans now are so in in
it that even they are like they're
they're almost in it and on it with you
at some point you know they it's very
it's it's like so intertwined which is a
it's a good thing but it's just so
strange to me now it's a thing I'm happy
about like I'm happy it's happening well
you started your own podcast me whiskey
ginger is doing well let's do good
people like it you have a lot of great
guests Ryan man yeah you got to get over
there we got to get you people people
ask me all the time when I'm gonna get
you and it's really funny sometimes
people make when fans make up [ __ ] it's
weird when they're like you guys don't
over you guys don't like each other how
where does this come from this weird
fake news that gets like infiltrated
into this thing like these lies that
they put in there that they didn't hear
yes it's strange they're like what are
you not hey would yo that's like no we
all are doing a million things trying to
create these worlds for people as much
as we can so we can keep you know
engaging in content and working and I
just don't I think people think that
like I think people think that we have
more time than the average human like
there's more chasm bigger clock for
comedians it's like how come you can't
do all these things like it's impossible
yeah it's too hard and I don't want to
show up and not be able to and like
their times but I don't feel like myself
where it's like I won't go on any you
know I didn't go in a lot of pockets or
wasn't feeling like super like myself
it's like I want to go and I'm having
fun you know yeah and like I'm gonna go
and bring the heat to fun yeah and I
want to have a blast like I don't it's
like that's sometimes - it's hard to
keep doing the job of podcasting when if
you're going through your own [ __ ] in
your own life because it's like okay you
know this isn't it you know it's hard to
show you know it's not
a self-pitying but it's just you know
it's it's a journey yeah well I think I
think people don't know that it's a
full-time job Rogan says that all the
time
he's always i gets my fits a job I have
a job he's like I have two jobs I've
standup not podcasting it's like oh yeah
it is a job it's a 100% a full-time job
of like you know balancing these worlds
it's not it's not as mindless or kind of
passe as people kind of think it is so
it's put a lot of stress on you too it's
like a thing that kind of just adds this
other comedic stress pressure you get to
listen you want to be engaging yeah you
want to know what's going on because
it's not fun when you're not like into
it you know you're not just yeah I don't
know it's what's the last one you did
that you weren't into Nick might even
know did you have a guest that wasn't
into it did you have someone over here
that you didn't connect with no I just
have had guests where you know I've just
learned over time to be sometimes you're
interviewing somebody and sometimes
you're just talking yeah and so I never
really have known good how to be like a
good interviewer you know I mean I don't
think I'm bad at it but I just I don't
have like a big plan you know so when I
listen back sometimes I'm like man I
wish I would have expressed my true
feelings sure in a comfortable way to
ask the questions I wanted to ask and so
that started to get on my nerves
sometimes like man I you know like the
wolf of Wall Street guy we had Amanda
Knox and like I wanted to sometimes you
know why don't you just ask this right
here you know you were feeling it and
and what's the fear I think it's just a
fear of like I guess a fear of them
judge me a fear that they're gonna think
I'm trying to take advantage of them
with Korea even though I'm cure you know
just curious I came here right that's
how that's how I look at it yeah so and
I think so some of it is like you have
to you know I think now I realized
somebody okay have a little bit more of
a plan like it's not like I'm trying to
squeeze a you know dirty juice out of
this person but ya have a plan like you
know this is kind of some things I want
to talk about and even say I'm to them
candidly like hey here's a couple things
I'd like to talk about can we talk about
these things for sure now just in case
yeah if they don't want to do it it's so
it's clean and clear communication goes
back to communication because then I'll
let it run in my head like oh man you
know you're not doing you got it tight
you know so I think yeah probably clear
communication is something that I'm
gonna work
or not work on that I'm doing you know
they're not feeling better about Anton
I'll just have it be fun you know just
to remember that it's comedy yeah we're
just [ __ ] around
yeah we don't [ __ ] know dude yeah we
don't know what are we not know Nick
nothing we don't know as I'm saying dude
if the feds show up Nick is your [ __ ]
hide anything you'll hide literally I
need you to do this right you like okay
I don't know nothing man
cops are coming I don't know nothing you
know so funny he has a nice face so
they'll believe him that's what they
said this is this dude that's what he
said a minute ago that's how he got
through Church it's just that a nice
face they're like Nick what happened is
I don't know dude a lot of lesbian women
are doing all pre chirring now and stuff
so we OB pastor since yeah really
my put that up lesbian pastorship yeah
lesbian to lesbian pastorship is that a
cruise as a boat crew not lesbian
hamster [ __ ] that's a boat full of
lesbian bastard no but that'd be fun bro
that would be fun
would they have gay cruises oh dude we
had to Gail I Bren she's a live across
the street from us nice you do donuts
Hitler what
well you spin out in your car really
only because I do you turn right there
because it was otherwise I had to go
down the street and do it I'll just do
lazy eye you just wanted to get out yeah
it had nothing but they were awesome
two gay librarians uh yeah one of them's
a lot but I think one of them wasn't
working but one of them worked in
fiction yeah lesbian bishop specific
where you looking for Stan gay lesbian
women those pastors or lesbian pastors
happening more often maybe LGBT clergy
more often lesbian pastors more often
married lesbian Baptist co-pastors say
Oh beloved they are if I have gay
children oh oh I don't know what they're
I want to know what the rest of this if
I have gay children if you had a gay kid
if you had a gay kid what what would
your what's your instinct of how you'd
feel about it you cool with that or
you'd be you do you wish they were
straight I think that there's probably
something in a lot of men at a like at a
guttural level where you want your
needs to go on so there could be like a
concern there like just said like a
Visser I don't know what this rule means
but like at a visceral like core level
yeah you know not I had a brain level
yeah at a brain level at a sexual level
you want that you want the the seed to
be passed on yeah so I think even if you
know whether it's so you want to have a
boy who is going to want to procreate
out of his wean out of his penis but I
can do that now yeah and so now yeah so
now I think it's not available so now I
think that yeah once you realize that
and read that article that that's
available then you wouldn't have any
concerns can I be real with you yeah I
don't have any care about carrying on
the gene really I just don't care yeah I
don't I don't I don't I just don't care
for some reason I don't know why it
never wasn't like not that I don't want
to have nothing I don't wanna have a kid
I'm saying was never a concern if I had
a boy so a boy could carry on a santino
name just didn't care I didn't care at
all for some reason I don't know I don't
know why I was always like it wouldn't
ever matter to me if I had to do it or a
chick I mean I'd rather have a dude just
cuz they're cheaper and less to deal
with you know you let him figure out
life on their own you put it outside
it'll come come back when it needs to
eat you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
check it yeah man it's a little bit more
you could set him on the porch a little
mm-hmm
they'll figure it out and you don't have
to worry about him really I mean there's
not much to be concerned about with a
woman you have to you want to protect
and aid and and you wanted them to feel
comfortable all the time with a boy you
want them to feel uncomfortable for some
reason you're like I want you to shake
him up and what yeah you might get him
[ __ ] sand than his sure when he's not
looking
hit him a few times yeah pull the tooth
out when he doesn't expect it and not
even a loose one just like a full-on in
one I just think there's something about
that but I never really cared for us I
don't know why that is I don't know why
I never really had that right dick on
his forehead was hip draw a dick on him
every night and every single night as
anyway excited man
mom it's not me goes to school with a
sharpie but yeah Sharpie permanent
marker every day he's gotta scrub it off
yeah I don't know whenever I was growing
up we had some kid named Scottie and uh
people everybody drew like swastikas on
his t-shirt and stuff well that's him so
me where you got off at aftercare one
day but nobody knew what they'd meant
they'd just seen it on pamphlets and
stuff and then people [ __ ] got Stukas
SCOTUS you see bunch of skaters then he
washed the shirt and he still wore for a
while and you could just see out like an
undercover uh anti-semite about a black
light you'd still see it I definitely do
it might have been written in a little
bit of seed you know but uh but um but
uh but yeah I'm a reward for a while
dude and uh they don't have any Jewish
kids in the area it was just something
people had seen on pamphlets you never
grew up in any Jewish kids no we had one
kid later on when I found that that um
was half Jewish and then my mother dated
a Jewish guy a half Jewish half black
gentleman for a while half G was happily
Drake yeah that's great my uh I always
saw swastikas as a kid on garages
graffiti on garages but they did him the
wrong way
oh yeah that was drew him wrong and so
my instinct was like I want to fix it
but I don't want to help the racism
right but it's just wrong
I hated that they [ __ ] it up now by my
first friend as a kid in a was it was a
Jewish guy I didn't know what that was
until I was much older but because they
had he taught me what a dreidel was I
just thought there were different
Christians I just thought there were
like another branch of Catholic or
whatever I had no idea but dreidels and
menorahs I didn't know what any of that
stuff meant it meant nothing his mother
always smelled so good
his name was Philip she was beautiful
they lived in our apartment building we
lived in an apartment building when I
was a kid and I would go to their
apartment their apartment was so much
nicer than ours mm-hmm
like we had an apartment that you that
was just an apartment that you rented
and you lived in they like did the
wallpaper you know I mean like they had
their building or no no no no this was
like a 40-story build it was downtown in
a high-rise but it just they just they
look like they lived in it we look like
yeah we looked like we were staying in
one yeah Oh total our apartment look
like an apartment you stayed in theirs
look like one they lived in it was just
it was really it was always nice
beautiful like the fixtures I always
remember like fixtures are really fancy
like the sink handles were nice and and
we had always the ball you know the ball
house you know I mean that's just a
regular apartment [ __ ] but yeah and I
didn't know till I was older that he was
Jewish and uh when I had to learn what
it was like oh I guess that's that's
what all that [ __ ] was I just thought
they were like a you know there's so
many forms of Christianity you don't
know any of them
you know I mean there's different
to this menu I just have this Catholic
there's a foul Hippolyta snake bow
metropolitan everything yeah margarita
yeah hazel there's so many different
levels I don't know any of them does
milk and margarita Kristin's yeah yeah
shout out to milk on margarita what was
that kid's name I like that glance I
think I like that video question stuff
that's so smart to get them to send in
video we have a lot of graders we have
one more through one more sounds good
that was Beckett by the way gang bro
that's a great name you remember the
Beckett the Beckett card the Becca card
oh the Beckett card catalog that main
name that was so dope dude see median
wifey went up ten cents forty eight
cents more Oh exactly not trading it
yeah mark yeah you're not gonna get it
Andre where I had a Levin Andre we're
rookie cards eleven hangout yeah yeah
that's really sad pan al Shawn Kemp was
it was the second-most card I ever had
besides Jordan had Shawn Kemp's I loved
Shawn Kemp that Don Russ card reason
he's like coming off of a dunk I think
oh dude any I know that picture yeah
it's like silver like around the edges
kind of yeah I had a I had so many Shawn
Kemp cards that at some point I was like
man Amaya Seattle fan like I didn't
really realize I was such a fanatic
about him first you can collect his sons
now he has a hole that he has enough
kids where you get a whole pack of a 36
yeah 36 and two of them are hard to get
for some reason I don't know I those
middle ones 96 must have been tough for
you Seattle Chicago I mean I grew up as
a greatest basketball player of all time
so it was really not even argument to be
really yeah yeah who are you wearing in
this on the wall here that number five
is John Paxton
oh honey Paxson this one of the greatest
three-point shooters for the Bulls have
ever had although he doesn't get enough
love because Steve Kerr kind of gets all
the shine because of now his lineage in
basketball but Johnny P was incredible
man he was so good but yeah I love that
Johnny Paxson Jersey and I wore that to
a game and BJ Armstrong was here when we
were playing the Lakers and he and he
made eye contact with me anyone like
this and and I and I and I was like I
ran up to him and I was like I'm such a
big fan and everybody around didn't know
who he was
yeah people had no idea who BJ Armstrong
was I was like it was so strange to be
with a guy that I thought was a legend a
legend and people didn't I just young
kids I don't think knew who that was
look at
I had the same BG Armstrong experience
at the gym I see him at the gym
sometimes I used to work it out at this
Equinox and uh and I would see him there
the first couple times I saw him like I
know this dude you know and every if
you're a white guy you always want to
know tall black dudes you let's see you
just sick so you just know right away
yeah and you want to know him like I
don't know I feel special yeah yeah yeah
no this guy does things I can't do so
and then at some point I just remember
like holy [ __ ] that's BJ Armstrong yeah
he was so good yeah so fun to watch you
go say hi to him at the gym yeah said I
do I mean then after that he would kind
of just say hey or what was going on
chat briefly you know but I think Iowa
State was playing one time and I said he
was watching the game but yeah it was a
chat a little bit about who was your
first celebrity but always nice
Michael Landon was supposed to come to
our town when I was growing up he did
never made it or there was a rumor that
he wasn't he never playing touchdown and
took off I don't know what happened
Skerton goes he supposed to come to the
fair to the camp to the parish fair but
uh it was the first celebrity that's a
great question maybe right when I got to
LA there was I was by that Andaz hotel
right next to the Comedy Store and
Tracey Armstrong Tracey no hmm is he the
comedian Tracy Morgan Tracy Morgan was
arguing with the police and they're
trying to arrest him for something and
he goes there's a [ __ ] white man
running around with a butcher knife and
y'all here asking me questions really he
deflected everything to the fact that
there was a white man it probably was
running down the street that had said
something to him the police left they
didn't go look for the guy eventually
whatever he was doing it didn't compare
to this world that he built of this
supposed man what a butcher looking for
the wrong person there's a butcher knife
reared a white boy running up and down
sunset I love Tracy read that
motherfucker's hilarious the first
celebrity that you saw he's the first
celebrity about Tom Selleck at the
airport no yeah my dad was like my dad
literally outlaw goes Tom Selleck
I'm calling his name out Tom Selleck and
Tom kind of turned he went like hey
that's rude don't yell out my [ __ ]
name I mean my dad was like I was like I
know yeah he says I was very
embarrassing thanks for that [ __ ] but
the first actually the first one that I
said hello to was the mom from The
Wonder Years no way really I loved her I
got her autograph on a napkin in an ice
cream shop my mother didn't even know
who she was I was like mom that's the
mom from The Wonder Years and she was
like she had no idea and then she said
my son really is a fan of yours and she
says oh my god it's so nice because she
was from Chicago she was back home and
not when they were in the middle of
shooting that show and I was she was she
was my TV mother
I love the wonder here so one of my
favorite shows yeah and I and she signed
a little napkin us and I still and I
still have it to this day she was so
nice and so sweet but she was like TV
mom yeah because she was like a
stay-at-home oh yeah she had all that
like my mom I never had a stay-at-home
mom she always had the stress of the mom
on her a little bit but like the love of
the husband like I want to do my best
but I got to kind of be here in the same
house TV families were so right Oh
something about a man and it made us all
look up to those families man dude IRA I
had lunch with Fred Savage recently
breakfast oh you did have it yeah yeah I
met him he directed this thing that I
did one time in a he's the voice of
Honda he's you ever hear a Honda
commercial he is the voice of Honda
that's amazing yeah a really neat guy
yeah good he's a good dude good do it
very tiny though he's smaller than I
thought yeah he never grew up after that
show that show stunted his growth long
would you do yeah all right let's see
that let I want to see this video I want
to see him that was my bad I got it I
got into the questioning this dude had a
quick question here from mr. Santino
that's cool how did you and a little
Dickie become tight it's a pretty cool
guy to know right now got with a lot of
influence and a really big name just
thought it was interesting y'all were
tight and wondered how how that came
about thanks a lot appreciate it
Gang Gang oh I like that high note at
the end yeah I like this dude he's like
me if my mom met a black guy that's like
me really look he's also he's such a
podcast fan he's got on Rogen in the
background with Dan Soder maybe there's
something I couldn't tell who was it
kept going by so fast I couldn't see
no I don't know who that is that's I
don't know who that is I can't tell but
yeah shout out thanks for this dude no
yeah I'm doing a show with little Dickie
people don't know who that is a funny
rapper he come he's got a show that
we're doing on FX that comes out in
March that's how we met we met cuz we're
doing the TV show together and he's a
funny dude man he wants to do comedy
more than rap but he doesn't want to do
stand-up but he wants to do comedic
television so I'll doing a live show no
we do have a scripted show oh wow yeah
for FX you said uh-huh and it's me and
him and a few other actors but a ton of
rappers are on it yg is on it
trippy red future there's a bunch of
people that make appearances mmm
it's cool I mean it's good I hope I hope
it's gonna be good I never you never
know what TV shows it's so weird man
alright you should do more TV shows
might Nick maybe next year you really
should man how did you meet him though
when I read for the show when I read for
the show we met when I read for the show
I was in his name's Dave and uh he was
like he was I could you just wanna do
you want to read these lines or do you
just want to just [ __ ] around cuz I
think he hits they had shown him me and
you know he had either see me or
whatever and then yeah we just [ __ ]
around the whole time man we just made
up a fake scene scenario hmm and we just
had a great time and that it was just
it's good it's kinda he wants it to be
kind of like the rap a rappers version
of curb you know like do you like the
hip-hop version of curb how did you feel
when you're on set me to feel like a
good show yeah it was funny I just I
never know with TV you know what I mean
like TV you never know what you're
making you know I mean like and there's
also so much scrutiny and television
that I try to just make it do my best
and I distance myself from it yeah
because I don't the negativity and the
hate and people that talk [ __ ] about
projects that you make I just don't want
to deal with it I don't like it like I
want to I make it and I push it away
like I usually never watch anything I do
that's too hard for me I don't like it
because then I'll get really critical
over what what I made and then I'll
start to agree with the hate do you
don't I mean oh yeah yeah yeah people
say something negative oh yeah that is
right I hate that too yeah it's like I
don't need to do that to myself like
there's no need to I do that sometimes
to drown myself in the thing that I
heard someone else being negative about
I need that [ __ ] yeah we don't need it
man yeah it just doesn't help it doesn't
help you know if you
means don't watch me don't talk to me
don't like me I don't care if you don't
like me you don't think I'm funny or
whatever you don't like my [ __ ]
I don't [ __ ] care don't watch my [ __ ]
I don't need you to tell me to do
something else yeah just do something
else bro I just don't need it anymore so
yeah I hope it's good
I I wish for the best for the show and I
put it out and we put some good work
into it and hopefully I'm like I don't
think he's gonna be good I'm just not
good at that I'm not good at pretending
like I know do you know what I mean yeah
because every time I see you something
every time I respect that though at
least you're not [ __ ] yeah most
people would have say this is the best
[ __ ] ever watch this [ __ ] and you're
like that's [ __ ] dog [ __ ] yeah
because I don't want to sell a lie like
is it good I think so I just I haven't
seen it that's the other thing is like
what's it called when will we see it
it's March 14th I think it's coming out
in March on FX and if right now it's
called Dave that's his first name Dave
but we don't know if they don't know if
they're gonna call it that yet but it's
great Jeff Shaffer is the EP of it he's
a guy who did the league launch of our
homies and he did curb this year
Jeff directed Curb Your Enthusiasm which
I got to do an episode of that was
bananas
I got an episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm
coming out me and Larry David and JB
Smoove JB JB so funny the funniest like
are too funny like to a degree where
you're like this is unfair how funny he
is in a scene he was knockout
he wasn't even posed to be in it he just
kind of like they inserted him in
because he showed up mm-hmm and me and
him were just [ __ ] with Larry and
they like he loved it Wow he was eating
it up yeah he wasn't it just wasn't be
me and Larry getting in this argument
and JB was like he just poked in in the
middle of the scene I think they had
been like go [ __ ] around because we had
gotten what we needed and he came in and
it changed the whole scene it was so
funny oh he's so funny minute yeah so
that was uh so yeah hopefully you know
hopefully uh the little Dickie show is
is a well received thing I just yeah I
don't know what TV coz I was being
honest with you it like they make you
promote the show right right that's a
good point too so you do want to promote
what's yours what you've been a part of
yeah so so like I'm I hope it's good and
I haven't seen it that's what people
also don't know is like when you shoot
[ __ ] you don't [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know
I'm not sitting the Edit Bay I don't
know what it's gonna turn out to be yeah
and a lot of times you get scrutiny over
things and you're like that's not what
it was when I did it you know I mean
that's it's like I don't know what it
turned what it's gonna end up being it's
got to go through this
Willy Wonka machine of like yeah I mean
oh yeah that's a great point so so I
hope so but yeah you got to do these
press tours when you do those things
half the time you do them and they make
you feel like you're supposed to be like
a cheerleader it's like I don't want to
be I don't wanna be like it's the
greatest thing I've ever done I mean let
me tell you something Jimmy like I don't
want to do that like I don't want to go
on Jimmy Kimmel and and play this like
hype card yeah it's hard to do cuz it's
just like I don't know it's no
disrespect to people that do it some
people are very good at that but like I
can't I couldn't I can't I can't do it
like I like it I hope it's good that's
all I can do like I'm dying up here was
the same thing you drove it and also you
know it's almost control over it like
you do your law you do your same as you
do your part yeah the only person that
has to really be concerned with that
stuff is Dave because it's his he wrote
the show it's his show you know what I
mean like yeah yeah I mean if props to
him you know I mean like he put in a lot
of work on he cares a lot about the
project and I do too but I have his much
much less influence in control hmm I'm a
great puzzle piece in the in the grand
scheme so we'll see what we really need
to do is like you and me Bobby Cal and a
bunch of us goofballs we need to we
joked about making a movie or a TV show
we really should man we would have so
much fun then then it'd be no rules
everybody always says it nobody does it
but it's like how do we do it you know
yeah we'd have to find what was what was
tangible like we have to find the thing
that's like like that we can hold on to
that we could really make something good
out of you know I mean yeah they can't
just be Bert showing his titties yeah
every scene although it is funny to have
him just walk into the scene show his
titties and then get out yeah I thought
wrestling I thought if we were all like
this shitty wrestling league yeah I
liked that I like but I think you get
pushback from people that don't like
wrestling that becomes like the whole
[ __ ] bro if they can't print let it
let us pretend that we're wrestlers I'm
saying yeah well I don't care I'll have
some whimsy man have some [ __ ] whims
isn't that that's gonna be the phrase of
the day as is now man Andrew Santino
thank you so much thank you yeah good
luck on the new tour man thank you a Red
Rocket tour Red Rocket or people I'm
doing 21 cities go to Andrew Santino
calm and check all that out and
hopefully I'm coming close to you I'm
trying my best to get to as many cities
as I can that yeah man it Congrats on
all your hard work and all your success
this year I know it's been a big year
for you and
thank you baby
[Music]
little town for me to sell their parking
brake and let myself
[Music]